on retrouve donc Bruno Le Maire ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle numérique
Thomas Cazenave Miss délégué chargé des
grands publics qui vont après être venus
ici lundi pour la loi de programmation
de finance publique nous présenter le
projet de finance pour 2024 adopter ce
matin au Conseil des ministres nous
devions être à l'origine également
additionner Bruno Le Maire le mercredi
20 septembre pour évoquer les
conséquences des Assises des finances
publiques qui se sont tenues en juin
2023 il a finalement paru plus
utile et efficace de regrouper cette
thématique avec celle relatives au PLF
2024 avec lesquels elle se confondent
largement les évoquer lors de l'audition
de ce jour concernant le calendrier
d'examen du PLF nous débuterons en
commission par l'examen de la première
partie le mardi 10 octobre
nous poursuivons les mercredis 11 et
jeudi 12 octobre le délai de dépôt des
amendements sera fixé au jeudi qui
précède à 17h en séance publique la
discussion de la première partie devrait
se dérouler du mardi 17 octobre au lundi
23 octobre en vue d'un vote solennel sur
l'ensemble de la première partie qui
devrait avoir lieu le mardi 24 octobre
près les questions au Gouvernement je
rappelle à ce propos qu'il faut que la
première partie du PS soit adoptée ou
considéré comme adopter avant de pouvoir
passer à l'examen de la seconde partie
l'examen de la seconde partie en
commission des finances commencera le
mardi 24 octobre jusqu'au mardi 31
octobre la Commission se cessera donc
successivement de toutes les missions
qui seront à l'ordre du jour de la
séance publique à compter du mardi 31
octobre et ce jusqu'au vendredi 17
novembre il faudra également examiner en
commission les articles non rattachés en
vue d'un passage en séance publique le
lundi 20 novembre le vote solennel sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 interviendrait donc le mardi
21 novembre monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle numérique
monsieur ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics c'est à vous qu'il
revient d'ouvrir ce marathon budgétaire
nous vous écoutons
merci Monsieur de président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur le ministre
cher Thomas madame et Messieurs les
Députés je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver pour vous présenter ce projet
de loi de finance pour 2024
nous le présentons dans un contexte
très singulier
l'économie française résiste 1% de
croissance
elle enregistre parmi les meilleurs
résultats de la zone Euro 2 millions
d'emplois créés au cours des 6 dernières
années une industrialisation qui
accélère 100 000 emplois industriels qui
ont été créés et un investissement des
entreprises qui se maintient
mais dans le même temps nous faisons
face à une crise inflationniste qui est
la plus grave depuis les années 1970 qui
entame la confiance de ménages qui
plonge les plus modestes de nos
compatriotes dans une véritable anxiété
sur ce sujet de l'inflation nous
marquons des points depuis plusieurs
semaines l'inflation reflux mais ça
n'est pas encore visible pour nos
compatriotes et je le redis en
particulier pour les plus modestes
d'entre eux
le deuxième défi qui est aussi celui du
PLF de 2024 c'est d'accélérer le
désendettement du pays et de réduire le
déficit
je veux dire à quel point cette ligne
définie des finances publiques saines
est un impératif catégorique
et j'appelle notre majorité à revenir à
l'esprit de 2017 à notre ADN politique
qui est celui des comptes publics bien
tenus de la réduction des déficits
publics et de la réduction de la dette
je le dis d'autant plus qu'on ne peut
pas dire que nous soyons vraiment aider
par les propositions d'économie de la
part des oppositions qui font un saut de
proposition de dépenses sur les
carburants sur d'autres sujets mais
assez peu de propositions d'économies
ou alors qui critiquent notre
trajectoire mais qui refuse dans le même
temps de voter soit la réforme
d'assurance chômage soit la réforme des
retraites qui sont pourtant ce qui amène
le plus d'économies et qui accéder à le
plus le désendettement du pays
cette ligne de responsabilité budgétaire
d'accélération du désendettement qui est
la ligne de la majorité elle est
d'autant plus nécessaire quand les taux
d'intérêt ont pris 300 points de base
l'argent gratuit c'est fini
et c'est fini pour longtemps
donc il serait totalement irresponsable
de poursuivre les dépenses au même
rythme au moment où les taux d'intérêt
ont atteint les 4% et alourdissent à
charge de la dette qui s'élèvera je le
rappelle à 74 milliards d'euros en 2027
enfin le troisième défi de ce PLF c'est
de dégager des marges de manoeuvre pour
investir dans le régalien chacun voit
bien la nécessité d'avoir des forces de
sécurité des forces armées à niveau
quand la guerre est de retour en Europe
investir dans la santé dans l'éducation
parce que ce sont les deux grands
services publics sur lesquels s'appuie
la nation française et investir
massivement et rapidement de la
transition écologique pour faire face au
réchauffement climatique voilà
l'équation qui est posée devant nous
voile l'équation que nous voulons
résoudre le pellet 2024 protéger contre
l'inflation des endettés et investir
ça suppose de financer ses
investissements et de piloter nos
finances publiques en faisant preuve de
beaucoup de fermeté et de beaucoup de
clarté beaucoup de fermetés cela veut
dire j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
répéter à plusieurs reprises que je
m'opposerai à toute augmentation
d'impôts toute augmentation de taxes qui
ne seraient pas déjà choisi dans le
cadre de la bascule la fiscalité brune
va la fiscalité verte et qui alourdirait
le taux de prélèvement obligatoire sur
nos compatriotes qui est déjà je le
rappelle le plus élevé de tous les pays
développés de la planète
notre premier défi c'est donc de mettre
fin à la flambée des prix
c'est notre objectif de court terme
et je tiens à rappeler que pour lutter
contre l'inflation le point de départ
c'est d'éviter de faire au niveau
national le contraire de ce qui est
décidé au niveau européen par la Banque
centrale européenne ou alors soyez
cohérence sortait de l'Europe mais tous
ceux qui me disent plus de dépenses
budgétaires
au moment où la Banque centrale
européenne réduit la voilure sur la
politique monétaire ça s'appelle appuyer
sur l'accélérateur quand le voisin
appuie sur le frein ça vous amène tout
droit dans le décor
si nous voulons que l'inflation baisse
ce qui est la première attente de nos
compatriotes la bonne réponse c'est pas
injecter toujours plus d'argent public
certainement pas c'est au contraire de
maîtriser la dépense publique de cibler
les aides sans quoi nous alimentons
l'inflation et tous ceux qui la main sur
le cœur font un sur le générosité en
réalité en réalité ne font qu'alimenter
l'inflation dont souffre nos
compatriotes c'est une règle économique
mais il est pas mauvais de les rappeler
je suis à demande aussi deuxième règle
que le fardeau de l'inflation soit
équitablement réparti
je vais être très simple là aussi l'État
va pas tout payer
ce serait injuste et ce serait
totalement inefficace pour nos comptes
publics l'étape prend déjà beaucoup à sa
charge mais il faut aussi je revendique
cette politique que les acteurs privés
des industriels les distributeurs
prennent leur charge alors certains
s'amusent je leur reconnais bien ce
droit bien entendu à dire vous n'arrêtez
pas de demander et vous n'obtenez rien
désolé nous obtenons quand nous
rassemblons les industriels et les
distributeurs pour leur dire il faut
qu'il y ait un plus grand nombre de
références de produits alimentaires dont
les prix sont bloqués ou dans les prix
baisses 5000 références dans les prix
sont bloqués ou dans les prix baisse
tous ceux qui nous proposent le blocage
universel des prix s'adresseront aux
agriculteurs qui seront bien contents
d'apprendre qu'on a bloqué les prix de
leurs produits alimentaires
il s'adresseront aux consommateurs qui
verront comme dans tous les pays où ça a
été pratiqué que quand on bloque les
prix mais il y a plus de produits dans
les rayons ça s'appelle la pénurie ça
s'appelle l'Union soviétique ça ne me
paraît pas avec la voix à suivre pour la
France et pour une grande économie de
marché comme l'économie française
nous avons obtenu de la part de
distributeur des efforts de leur part
trimestre anti-inflation maintient
obèses des prix sous 5000 produits
avancer de la conclusion des
négociations commerciales au 15 janvier
2024 blocage du prix de Total à 1,99 €
le litre dans ces 3000 stations partout
en France et engagement des
distributeurs à distribuer les
carburants à prix coûtant à la pompe
jusqu'à la fin de l'année
pour ceux qui relève de l'État nous
avons avec le président de la République
pris la décision de cibler l'aide sur
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin ceux qui
travaillent
certains peuvent limiter leur
déplacement d'autres ne le peuvent pas
parce que tout simplement ils doivent se
rendre sur le lieu de travail à
l'origine dans leur hôpital et ils ont
besoin d'être accompagnés l'indemnité
carburant transport c'est 100 euros par
voiture pour ceux qui bossent elle sera
mis en place en janvier elle permettra à
tous ceux qui travaillent de se rendre
sur le travail sans se demander si ne
perdent pas de l'argent à aller
travailler c'est donc une mesure
nécessaire et si tu ne mesure juste qui
coûtera 430 millions d'euros
enfin je rappelle ce qu'on oublie trop
souvent que l'État prend toute sa part
par un mécanisme majeur qui est celui de
l'indexation de l'ensemble des
prestations sociales
l'indexation de toutes les retraites et
l'indexation du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu sur le niveau de l'inflation
toutes les retraites seront revalorisées
de
5,2%. tous les minima sociaux seront
protégés contre l'inflation par cette
indexation
et pas un Français ne rentrera dans
l'impôt sur le revenu en raison du
barème puisque nous indexons le niveau
du barème sur l'inflation si nous ne
l'avions pas fait c'était 320 000 de nos
compatriotes qui allaient être soumis à
l'impôt alors qu'ils ne le sont pas
aujourd'hui et ceux qui n'ont pas eu la
chance d'être suffisamment augmenté par
leur entreprise qui sont augmentées de 1
ou 2%, ils verront leurs impôts baissés
puisque la réévaluation du barème sur le
niveau de l'inflation leur permettra
d'avoir des impôts qui baissent cette
indexation elle représente dans le
budget que je vous présente aujourd'hui
avec Thomas Cazenave 25 milliards
d'euros de dépenses en 2024
4,5 milliards pour l'indexation des
prestations sociales 14 milliards pour
les retraites 6 milliards d'euros pour
l'indexation du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu et là aussi je profite de cette
rencontre politique au sens noble du
terme avec l'ensemble des parlementaires
pour tordre le cou et cette idée fausse
comme quoi l'État se rempliraient les
poches en période d'inflation on me dit
mais avec l'inflation les recettes de
TVA explosent mais arrêtons avec les
mots mettant des chiffres c'est 10
milliards d'euros les recettes
supplémentaires de TVA en 2024 liée à
l'augmentation des prix et rien que pour
les indexations il y a déjà plus du
double de dépenses 25 milliards d'euros
la réalité c'est que quand il y a
inflation l'état perd de l'argent
il faut vraiment raisonner à courte vue
ou aimer le mensonge pour prétendre que
lorsque l'inflation est là l'État s'en
mettrait plein les poches il est obligé
de protéger il est obligé d'indexer et
ça lui coûte plus cher que ça ne lui
rapporte
deuxième défi
accélérer le désendêtement c'est notre
objectif cette fois de moyen terme celui
qui est fixé par la loi de programmation
des finances publiques qui nous occupera
ce soir pour une durée dont on verra ce
qu'elle sera
dans cette loi de programmation de
finance publique notre objectif est de
revenir sous les 3% de déficit 2,7%
exactement et de ramener la dette à
108%, tout en baissant le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire de 1 point de
45,4 à 44,4 raison pour laquelle il me
paraît sage de tenir cette trajectoire
car un point de prélèvement obligatoire
en moins de nous mènera toujours qu'à
44,4% de prélèvement obligatoire ce qui
reste très lourd pour nos compatriotes
pour tenir ce chemin faut que le premier
pas soit le bon c'est celui du PLF 2024
dans ce PLF 2024 il y a donc 16
milliards d'euros d'économies 10
milliards d'euros de fin du bouclier
tarifaire
4,4 milliards d'euros de recentrage et
dispositif d'aide exceptionnelle aux
entreprises et un milliard sur les
politiques de l'emploi dont 600 millions
sur les coûts contrats des apprentis
s'ajoutent à cela 700 millions d'euros
résultat de la mise en œuvre de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage avec ces
économies l'État va dépenser
491 milliards en 2024 contre 496 en 2023
c'est donc 5 milliards d'euros de moins
l'état réduit la voilure l'état réduit
ses dépenses l'État dépense mieux et
l'État engage sont désendettement c'est
un impératif catégorique à tous ceux qui
me diront ça y est l'austérité de retour
je le recommande d'aller voir dans
d'autres pays européens ce que signifie
l'austérité ou de revenir 10 ans en
arrière ils verront que c'est quelque
chose d'assez radicalement différent et
que parler d'austérité quand on a encore
plus de 54% notre richesse nationale qui
est consacrée à la dépense publique
c'est appelé noir ce qui est blanc ce
budget 2024 est donc bien la première
marche d'une trajectoire plus réelle des
finances publiques ambitieuses qui
reposent sur une stratégie claire et
volontariste de désendettement dont le
premier pilier est la croissance la
croissance est indispensable pour ceux
des endetter et c'est ça qui nous a
amené à maintenir la baisse d'impôts sur
les entreprises un milliard d'euros de
CVAE en moins et d'envisager une baisse
de 2 milliards d'euros d'impôts sur les
ménages en 2025 parce que c'est ce qui
facite la croissance et la production de
richesse de la part de nos entreprises
le deuxième levier ce sont les réformes
de structure j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure réforme des retraites réformes
l'assurance chômage qui a L2
rapporteront 25 milliards d'euros en
2027 enfin le troisième levier ce sont
les revues des dépenses publiques cette
revue des dépenses publiques était
engagée en 2023 elle sera poursuivie
chaque année
elle étudiera l'ensemble des dépenses
publiques sans exception elle comportera
chaque année 15 secteurs nouveaux avec
un objectif
financer les 12 milliards d'euros
d'économie nécessaire en 2025 qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas documentés nous
avons 6 mois devant nous pour les
documentés je profite la présentation de
ce PLF pour dire que toutes les bonnes
volontés parlementaires sont les
bienvenues pour travailler avec nous sur
ces revues de dépenses publiques qui
nous est déjà permis d'identifier deux
milliards d'euros d'économie à terme
pour mieux cibler la dépense publique et
la rendre plus efficace et je profite
aussi de cette rencontre politique
importante
pour être très clair avec vous et en
particulier avec les parlementaires de
la majorité ces revues de dépenses
publiques sont nécessaires elles ne sont
pas suffisantes
pour être efficace pour être durable
elle doit s'inscrire dans une réflexion
plus globale sur les missions de l'État
sur le périmètre de l'action publique et
sur nos choix fondamentaux de politique
sociale que chacun réalise que notre
modèle social et public n'est pas
soutenable sans réforme de structure en
profondeur et que si nous voulons
continuer à soigner gratuitement ce que
non le plus besoin à éduquer dans les
meilleures conditions à protéger avec
efficacité il faut que l'État repense
ses missions que dans votre modèle
social soit réinventé il ne peut pas
fonctionner à perte ou à crédit j'engage
tous les parlementaires de la majorité
dans ce travail qui reposera à la fois
sur les revues de dépenses et dans le
même temps sur une redéfinition du
périmètre de l'action de l'État et du
fonctionnement de notre modèle social
je le dis avec gravité parce que je
pense que nous sommes arrivés au bout
d'un chemin ou des économies
conjoncturelles seraient suffisantes
c'est une réflexion structurelle qu'il
faut mener c'est celle à laquelle nous
engager le président de la République
depuis 6 ans c'est celle qui fait
l'identité de notre famille politique et
notre majorité et c'est à elle que nous
devons être fidèles dans les années qui
viennent c'est ce qui nous évitera des
révisions déchirantes ou des décisions
prises dans l'urgence
le troisième défi le troisième enjeu de
ce projet de loi de finance c'est
l'investissement pour préparer l'avenir
c'est notre objectif de long terme il
est indispensable parce qu'il n'y a pas
de désendettement de réduction de
déficit sans croissance
ce choix nous a conduit à baisser un
certain nombre d'impôts taxe
d'habitation suppression la contribution
audiovisuelle publique baisse de l'impôt
sur les sociétés cap qui nous a permis
de créer 2 millions d'emplois d'engager
leur industrialisation de la France et
comme je le disais de conserver une
croissance positive à 1% quand beaucoup
de nouveaux uns européens aujourd'hui
sont en récession
cette politique sera poursuivie
politique de l'offre qui défend l'emploi
qui défend le travail qui soutient les
entreprises et qui abaissent la pression
fiscale
je rappelle que les entreprises avec ce
PLF bénéficieront également de
conditions de concurrence fiscale
équitable à l'échelle internationale
grâce à la mise en place de l'imposition
minimale à l'impôt sur société dit
piliers 2 il sera mis en place des EPLF
2024 et il rapportera 1,5 milliards
d'euros par an à partir de 2026 preuve
qu'on peut être à la fois efficace et
juste
les grands choix d'avenir de ce PLF 2024
vous les connaissez la sécurité et le
régalien avec les lois de programmation
sur la justice sur la police et sur les
armées qui seront scrupuleusement
respectés la priorité donnée par le
Président de la République à l'éducation
et à la santé et enfin le choix de
politique décisif en faveur de la
décarbonation et de la transition
écologique rappelée par le Président de
la République lundi et pas la première
ministre hier soir nous augmentons donc
le budget consacré à ma prime rénov
qui sera porter à 5 milliards d'euros
par an soit 1,6 milliards d'euros de
plus c'est un effort considérable nous
amplifierons nos efforts sur les
véhicules électriques nous augmenterons
le bonus automobile pour les classes
moyennes et les personnes les plus
modestes nous ouvrirons en novembre les
prêts réservations pour un leasing à 100
euros par mois pour les 50% de ménage
les plus modestes avec je le rappelle un
premier loyer qui sera intégralement
pris en charge par l'État nous
favoriserons aussi la production
d'énergie nucléaires avec les
discussions qui sont actuellement en
cours avec EDF pour avoir un prix de
l'énergie qui se rapproche le plus
possible du coût moyen de production de
l'électricité en France nous ne voulons
plus que le coût de l'électricité en
France soit indexé sur le coût marginal
d'ouverture de la centrale à gaz la
dernière centrale à gaz dans l'Est de
l'Europe nous voulons que les français
payent le prix de la production en
France par les énergies renouvelables ou
par le nucléaire
et pas une fois encore le coût marginal
de l'ouverture de la dernière centrale à
gaz européenne
enfin ces investissements dans la
décarbonation suppose aussi d’engager la
conversion de notre fiscalité
nous allons pas mettre en place des
avantages fiscaux sur l'industrie verte
et sur la bicarbonation tout en gardant
des avantages fiscaux sous énergies
fossiles là c'est complètement Shadow
tien si vous payez des deux côtés il y a
fort à penser que ça ne mènera
absolument nulle part et je veux saluer
l'esprit de responsabilité des secteurs
qui sont concernés nous sommes parvenus
un accord avec nos amis agriculteurs et
avec les entrepreneurs des travaux
publics sur la réduction de l'avantage
fiscale sur le Gazole Non Routier preuve
que une transition écologique qui n'est
pas imposée mais discuter
qui n'est pas laisse pas les gens seuls
mais qui les accompagnent qui apportent
des solutions au lieu de mettre les gens
face à des problèmes c'est une
transition écologique qui fonctionne il
y a trois ou quatre ans lorsque nous
présentions ce budget nous avions dit
que nous pouvions supprimer l'avantage
fiscal sur le gêné en un seul PLF ce
guide aperçu que c'était pas possible un
reporté au palais suivant c'est vite
aperçu c'était pas possible la reporter
opérer suivant vous pouvez continuer
comme ça encore très longtemps je pense
qu'il est de meilleure méthode de
discuter avec les secteurs concernés
discuter avec les agriculteurs
directement impactés voient avec eux ce
qui est possible voit avec eux ce qui
est raisonnable et les accompagner
concrètement
les agriculteurs verront la fiscalité
sur le GNR augmenté de 2,85 centimes par
litre de carburant en 2024 cette
augmentation sera la même jusqu'en 2030
elle ne bougera pas et l'intégralité des
revenus fiscaux liés cette augmentation
de la fiscalité sur le GNR ira à la
compagnement des agriculteurs et la mise
en place d'une filière de bio carburant
au total sur cette transition écologique
qui est une priorité absolue nous
consacrerons plus de 40 milliards dans
ce PLF soit une hausse de 7 milliards
d'euros en crédit de paiement et 10
milliards d'euros en engagement par
rapport à 2023 je crois que nous
pouvions pas marquer plus clairement
cette priorité du président de la
République et de la majorité
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général monsieur le ministre
Bruno mesdames et messieurs les députés
je suis très heureux de retrouver
aujourd'hui de nouveau la commission des
finances de l'Assemblée nationale pour
vous présenter avec Bruno Le Maire le
projet de loi de finance pour 2024 ce
budget est le résultat d'une méthode
celle du dialogue j'y reviendrai d'un
esprit celui de la responsabilité et
d'une boussole agir pour l'avenir
d'abord le projet de loi de finance pour
2024 consacre la transition écologique
comme une priorité absolue avec ce
budget permettant un financement
historique de la transition écologique à
côté de notre dette financière nous
avons une dette écologique à laquelle ce
budget permet de s'attaquer le projet de
loi de finance prévoit l'investissement
supplémentaire de 10 milliards d'euros
annoncés par le Président de la
République et la première ministre dans
le cadre de notre stratégie de
planification écologique
c'est 10 milliards d'euros se traduisent
par une hausse des crédits de paiement
de 7 milliards d'euros en 2024 et ce
chiffre correspond à la mise en oeuvre
de la planification écologique je vous
en donne quelques exemples très concrets
en matière de transport nous permettront
la construction de RER métropolitain
pour 550 millions d'euros pour l'État
nous engageons des rénovations
thermiques des bâtiments pour
l'agriculture un exemple parmi bien
d'autres la mise en oeuvre du plan et
qui bénéficiera de 110 millions d'euros
d'engagement le fond chaleur recevra 300
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour le
chauffage urbain et la décarbonation du
chauffage les entreprises et des ménages
nos collectivités territoriales
bénéficieront aussi de cet
investissement puisque le fond vert est
pérennisé à hauteur de 2,5 milliards
d'euros dont 500 millions d'euros pour
la rénovation des écoles comme
l'annoncer le président de la République
nous inciterons par ailleurs tous les
acteurs à s'engager en faveur de la
transition écologique en créant un
crédit d'impôt pour l'investissement
dans l'industrie verte pour soutenir la
décarbonation notre industrie mais aussi
en renforçant les malus automobile pour
les véhicules les plus polluants nous
cherchons à amplifier tous les leviers
de financement de la transition
écologique en dotant le futur plan
d'épargne action climatique d'un régime
fiscal incitatif et en mettant à
contribution les gestionnaires des
infrastructures de transport les plus
émetteurs pour financer le ferroviaire
alors cette étape franchie en 2024 pour
la transition et écologique et
naturellement un engagement de long
terme lundi lors de l'examen ici même en
commission des finances du projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
nous avons donné un avis favorable à un
amendement déposé à l'initiative de
plusieurs députés notamment David Amiel
et Pierre Cazeneuve du groupe
Renaissance qui prévoit l'établissement
d'une stratégie pluriannuelle des
financements de la transition écologique
cet amendement rejoint plusieurs
amendements qui ont été déposés par
l'opposition ce n'est donc pas une
surprise et elle correspond à une
demande de visibilité exprimée par tous
les groupes lors des dialogues de Bercy
les collectivités ont aussi un rôle
majeur à jouer nous travaillons avec les
associations d'élus pour permettre la
généralisation des budgets verts dans
les collectivités territoriales l'enjeu
est de nous doter d'une boussole commune
là aussi cela permettra dans le cadre de
notre débat parlementaire d'enrichir le
texte initial j'en suis certain
ce budget est aussi celui du réarmement
des services publics pour nos
concitoyens nous investissons
massivement dans nos services publics
qui sont garants de notre cohésion
nationale l'augmentation est de plus de
3,9 milliards d'euros pour l'éducation
nationale un milliard d'euros pour la
recherche et l'enseignement supérieur
plus de 3 milliards d'euros pour l'armée
un milliard d'euros pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur 500 millions d'euros pour la
justice
ces financements permettront
concrètement d'améliorer la rémunération
de nos enseignants de poursuivre le
programme d'investissement dans les
matériels prévus par la loi de
programmation militaire de mieux équipés
nos policiers mais au-delà de ces
chiffres le service public ce sont des
femmes et des hommes ce budget 2024 va
permettre de recruter près de 6700
agents publics supplémentaires dans
l'état et 1580 dans les opérateurs de
l'État nous créons 3000 postes d'aesh en
2024 1900 postes au sein de la justice
2600 personnels supplémentaires dans la
police 700 agents supplémentaires au
ministère de la transition écologique je
veux le dire très clairement s'il était
besoin ses créations sont une réponse à
ceux qui nous reprochent d'avoir
délaissé nos services publics rien n'est
plus faux
et enfin qu'on arrête d'opposer l'État
et les collectivités territoriales nous
portons ensemble les services publics
les concours financiers de l'État aux
collectivités s'élèvent à
54,8 milliards d'euros en 2024 et la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
augmentera de nouveau cette année de 220
millions d'euros après une hausse de
2023 qui était la première j'insiste
depuis 12 ans
et nous avons par ailleurs décidé
d’étendre et je sais que de très
nombreux parlementaires ici le
défendaient le fond de compensation de
la TVA aux dépenses d'aménagement cela
répond une demande des élus locaux et
représente un effort supplémentaire de
250 millions d'euros mais cette appli
que nous
portons au collectivités doit aller de
paires aussi avec la réduction du coût
des doublons entre l'État et les
opérateurs entre l'État les opérateurs
et les collectivités avec la réduction
du coût des normes nous lancerons
prochainement une grande mission sur ce
sujet pour alimenter des pistes de
réforme structurelles ce projet de loi
de finance ce sont aussi des grands
équilibres avec un cap clair rappelé par
Bruno Le Maire celui de la réduction de
nos déficits publics investir pour
l'avenir c'est maîtriser nos comptes
publics
et s'il est un a pu protéger c'est qu'il
avait réduit son déficit en 2018 à 2,3%.
un état qui consacre plus aux intérêts
de la dette qu'au budget de l'Éducation
nationale ce qui sera le cas en 2027 ne
peut plus prétendre à être tourné vers
l'avenir les dépenses de l'État vont
passer de 496 milliards d'euros à 491
milliards d'euros cette baisse elle est
historique elle s'explique d'abord par
la sortie des dispositifs de crise et je
vais vous dire les choses de manière
tout à fait directe les mesures
exceptionnelles mises en place au plus
haut pendant la crise énergétique ne
sont pas éternelles nous n'en n'avons
pas les moyens
nous devons sortir progressivement des
dispositifs de crise qui pèsent sur nos
finances publiques et nous dépenserons
14 milliards d'euros de moins sur les
mesures exceptionnelles en 2024 et dans
le même temps nous devons continuer à
lutter contre la vie chère et redonner
du pouvoir d'achat aux Français c'est
pour cela que nous
les tranches du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu
revalorisant les pensions les minimas
sociaux l'équivalent de 25 milliards
d'euros pour protéger les Français c'est
un véritable bouclier contre l'inflation
les économies sur le budget viennent
aussi des réformes structurales nous
ferons 350 millions d'euros d'économies
sur la politique de l'emploi en
cohérence avec la baisse du chômage
ainsi que 500 millions d'euros en
améliorant l'efficience de la politique
de formation professionnelle le déficit
budgétaire va ainsi passer de 165
milliards d'euros à 145 milliards
d'euros et nous tiendrons la cible des
4,4% de sol de public en 2024 nous
poursuivons de manière méthodique le
regrettement le redressement progressif
de nos comptes publics et nous devrons
continuer sur cette lancée pour les
prochaines années
soyons clairs notre trajectoire prévoit
que nous fassions 12 milliards d'euros
d'économie en 2025 c'est un effort très
conséquent et c'est dans ce cadre là que
nous relançons les revues de dépenses
ce PLF est aussi un PLF anti fraude
avant d’être un enjeu financier la lutte
contre la fraude est un enjeu de
cohésion et de justice sociale il n'y a
pas de consentement à l'impôt si nous ne
sommes pas en mesure de garantir de
garantir à nos concitoyens que tous ceux
qui doivent payer des impôts les payent
effectivement donc le projet de loi de
finances
et le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale vont instaurer une
dizaine d'outils juridiques
supplémentaires pour mieux lutter contre
la fraude je vous en donne quelques
exemples face à la nouvelle donne
numérique nos administrations pourront
défencer les vendeurs sur les
plateformes numériques qui ne respectent
pas leurs obligations fiscales ou
permettre à nos agents de mener des
cyber enquêtes sous pseudonymes nous
lutterons contre ceux qui achètent à
l'étranger sur Internet et revendre en
France sans payer la TVA nous créerons
une peine complémentaire de privation du
bénéfice des crédits et réductions
d'impôts pour les particuliers condamnés
pour fraude fiscale nous mettrons en
place un nouveau délit d'incitation à la
fraude fiscale afin de poursuivre tous
les intermédiaires qui proposent des
montages d'évasion fiscale sans attendre
la condamnation de leurs clients
c'est une manière d'empêcher la fraude à
la source pour ceux qui vendent la
fraude et ce délit concernera aussi les
personnes promouvantes la fraude aux
aides sociales comme la récemment fait
un youtubeur nous y travaillons nous
créerons une sanction administrative
pour lutter contre la fraude aux aides
publiques et nous mettrons en place dans
le PLFSS le précompte des cotisations
des travailleurs des plateformes pour
leur créer des droits et éviter la
fraude enfin nous renforcerons l'arsenal
pour mieux contrôler les arrêts maladie
en parallèle de la création de 1500
emplois au sein du contrôle fiscal à
Bercy d'ici 2027 c'est l'arrivée de
mille agents supplémentaires chargés de
la lutte contre la fraude au sein des
caisses de sécurité sociale qui est
prévu
enfin nous devons renforcer la sécurité
de nos agents qui effectuent les
contrôles en permettant la
délocalisation de certains contrôles et
on assouplissant la procédure
d'anonymisation des contrôles c'est une
évolution essentielle je le dis après le
drame que nous avons connu l'an dernier
il salait il s'agit là des mesures que
nous proposons dès le texte initial mais
nous sommes prêts à l'enrichir lors des
dialogues de Bercy la lutte contre la
fraude a été évoquée par la plupart des
participants certains ont proposé de
pérenniser le dispositif des aviseurs
fiscaux nous y sommes très favorables
enfin ce PLF est une méthode
salut dialogue j'y suis très attaché
c'est pourquoi depuis mon arrivée j'ai
réuni les parlementaires de tout bord
lors des dialogues de Bercy ou de
réunion bilatérales et je remercie
chacune et chacun d'entre vous qui ont
participé à ces échanges et qui nous a
permis d'identifier un certain nombre de
sujets de travail commun d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui a permis aussi lors de
l'examen de la LPFP d'émettre un avis
favorable à une quinzaine d'amendements
à la fois de la majorité et des
oppositions
cette méthode de dialogue éprouvée avec
vous vous avec tous c'est aussi main
dans la main avec les collectivités
territoriales que nous avons travaillé
ce budget dans l'esprit du pacte
Girondins du président de la République
nous avons créé avec Bruno Le Maire le
Haut Conseil au finances publiques
locales pour échanger d'égal à égal
entre l'État et les collectivités
territoriales et enfin et pour finir
s'agissant du PLF plusieurs thématiques
sont ressorties fortement de nos
dialogues notamment la question du
logement la question de la justice
fiscale ou de la transition écologique
je le redis ici nous serons ouverts à
vos propositions le texte que vous avez
dans les mains et le texte initial ce
n'est pas le texte final je remercie
bien merci messieurs les ministres
quelques observations et quelques
questions en préambule je crois qu'on a
un matière à avoir un beau débat
budgétaire à l'Assemblée je dirais même
à bien peut-être aussi un débat de
société donc j'espère que nous l'aurons
de façon de façon argumentée et
intéressant les Français en tout cas moi
je m'engage à faire en sorte que ce soit
le cas et la deuxième chose ça va
peut-être paraître être un voeux pieux
mais j'espère que si des bancs de la
majorité des bancs de cette assemblée
des majorités s'expriment pour des
propositions qui ne sont pas forcément
contenues dans ce budget initial le
gouvernement
sera les voir de manière positive
même si j'ai bien compris que pour
l'instant vous mettez des certaines
lignes rouges
je voudrais commencer par dire que dans
les mesures de de baisse des dépenses
publiques que vous proposez
la plupart ont un gros défaut à mon sens
c'est que finalement elles vont
s'attaquer encore un peu plus au pouvoir
d'achat des Français notamment des plus
défavorisés je pense à la question par
exemple des franchises médicales sur le
PLFSS je pense aussi à la fin du
bouclier énergétique
même si j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure
dans les questions il me semble que les
annonces du président de du chef de
l'État sur le chèque carburant tant à
nous laisser un peu dubitatif sur cette
véritable femme j'y reviendrai
et tout ça touche la question de
l'inflation je vous ai entendu Bruno Le
Maire vous avez expliqué que c'est pas
que l'État qui pouvait prendre sa part
sur la question de l'inflation
je regarderai un peu le ce que vous avez
fait comme démonstration sur le prorata
contre les recettes et ce que ce que
rapporte l'inflation à l'état est-ce que
ça coûte mais je voudrais tout de suite
ajouter quelque chose aujourd'hui
l'inflation est payée par une très
grande majorité de nos concitoyens tous
ceux qui ont des salaires non indexés
tous ceux qui ont des allocations
minimales pour vivre non indexées et si
il faut regarder ceux qui profitent de
l'inflation il faut davantage regarder
sur la question des marges des
entreprises que justement sur la
question des salaires donc l'inflation
comme malheureusement d'ailleurs souvent
aujourd'hui en tout cas de manière très
claire c'est
ceux qui n'ont que leur force de travail
pour vivre qu'il la paye et avec
évidemment un problème corollaire c'est
que c'est ceux qui permettent
d'alimenter la consommation populaire
donc c'est un lien avec l'activité
économique
deuxième réflexion que critique que je
fais après avoir lu succinctement votre
budget c'est que je considère que ça ne
répond pas aux besoins de la population
du moins les besoins les plus cruciaux
je commencerai par la transition
énergétique vous annoncez cette milliard
d'euros je pense qu'on est loin du
compte et de ce qui serait nécessaire
notamment annoncé par le rapport
pisaniferi sur les 37 milliards certes
en 2027 mais dont on voit bien que pour
arriver à 37 milliards je parle là
simplement de la part publique en 2027
il faudrait commencer à plus de 7
milliards aujourd'hui donc je ne crois
pas que nous soyons à la hauteur de
l'enjeu climatique et de la dette
écologique qui ne cesse de croire
deuxième chose je ne prends qu'un
exemple puisque je pourrais aussi parler
de la santé EHPAD mais je crois pas non
plus qu'il soit à la hauteur même si
j'ai entendu dans les dialogues de Bercy
de la part notamment de Thomas Cazenave
et de Bruno Le Maire que vous
considériez oui que c'était un chantier
ouvrir mais pour l'instant on est loin
du compte sur la question du logement
qui menace le pays d'implosion sociale
et je mesure mes mots dans ce que je
suis en train de dire
j'ai bien vu que vous étiez ouvert sur
la question Airbnb tout ce qui touche à
Airbnb résidence secondaire etc j'ai vu
avec inquiétude que pour résoudre
peut-être dans l'urgence la question
vous envisagiez qu'on laisse louer des
passoires thermiques je dois dire que
penser que l'environnement le climat
peut être encore une variable
d'ajustement dans la période membre
dubitatif mais ça ne répond pas la
question à la fois urgente et puis aussi
un moyen terme du manque de logement de
ce pays du fait que le logement est trop
cher et du fait que ça craque partout
bon donc je pense que ce budget ne
répond pas aux besoins des Français et à
mon sens c'est de là qu'il faut partir
troisième chose
vous avez quand même des difficultés et
quelques contradictions quelques
contradictions parce que au fond si je
regarde la loi de programmation des
finances publiques vous annoncez des
baisses de dépenses publiques mais
celles qui vont à un moment taper dans
le dur du dur c'est 2025 bon avec 12
milliards que vous annoncez nos
documenté qui si on comprend bien
devrait cette fois touché de manière
encore plus importante des services
publics essentiels des dépenses
publiques essentielles à nos concitoyens
bien et
ça me laisse dubitatif ici et une des
raisons peut-être pour lesquelles
finalement tout ça est reporté à 2025
c'est peut-être finalement un constat
que vous vous refusez de faire mais qui
touche les chiffres annoncés de
croissance en 2023 vous avez raison de
dire Bruno Le Maire que les économistes
estimaient que la France atteindrait pas
1% de croissance en 2023 vous avez
raison de le faire mais il faut
peut-être se demander pourquoi pourquoi
sommes-nous différents membres de
l'Allemagne qui est rentré en récession
et est-ce qu'au fond la raison pour
laquelle la France a plutôt mieux
résisté que les autres pays européens
n'est pas dû à ce que vous critiquez par
ailleurs en permanence c'est-à-dire le
fait que elle a un taux de dépenses
publiques supérieur justement à ces pays
européens qui en cas de reflux
économique permet justement de soutenir
l'activité économique moi je ne crois
profondément d'ailleurs ça a été observé
après la crise de 2008 or
je devrais la parole or
je crains que l'an prochain cette
réalité soit
moins atteinte d'ailleurs Pierre
Moscovici a même ce matin que il
estimait que les 1,4% de croissance ne
serait pas atteint notamment de ce fait
là et qu'on soit en situation où le
déficit annoncé à mon avis sera
supérieur mais ça on pourra se tenir
rendez-vous la fin de l'année autre
point que je voulais souligner vous
dites
c'est fini distribuer gratuitement
l'argent gratuit c'est fini pardon mais
est-ce que le corollaire de l'argent
gratuit c'est fini c'est pas de se dire
que il faudra peut-être que ça soit fini
gratuitement au plus riche quoi voilà
c'est à dire que les dépenses fiscales
que vous avez accumulées pendant des
années dont certaines ont alimenté
considérablement les plus riches de nos
concitoyens
ces dernières années et bien est-ce que
alors déjà je pense que c'était déjà pas
supportable en temps normal mais est-ce
que c'est encore plus supportable quand
les taux d'intérêt remontent moi je ne
crois pas je crois qu'à partir du moment
on a besoin de recettes et vous le dites
et d'ailleurs c'est aussi la réponse
Bruno Le Maire je vous fais quand vous
dites j'attends des oppositions qu'elle
nous disent quelle haute dépense réduire
je vous le dis très clairement qui est
l'autre dépense réduire c'est d'aller
chercher l'argent là où il a été
accumulé et de manière considérable
c'est-à-dire dans la poche de nos
concitoyens les plus riches qui vivent
du capital auquel que vous avez très
largement j'allais dire des indexé par
rapport à la position du travail
je vous ai posé cette question Bruno Le
Maire lors des dialogues de Bercy
notamment en lien avec l'étudie PP qui a
été faite avec Bercy sur l'accumulation
le fait que le taux d'imposition globale
des 370 plus riches en France étaient
d'environ 25% si on cumule impôt sur le
revenu impôt sur professionnel vous
m'avez dit que c'était un constat que
vous pouviez partager mais vous le
renvoyez au niveau européen moi ma
question c'est pourquoi on renvoie au
niveau européen des mesures qui touchent
les plus riches de nos concitoyens et
qui pourraient rapporter des milliards à
l'État et par contre on renvoie pas au
niveau européen le fait de s'attaquer
aux retraites au chômeur ou je l'ai dit
encore à d'autres mécanismes là il y a
pas de problème on peut le faire au
niveau national
voilà un petit peu les observations que
je voulais vous faire et de cela j'ai
quelques questions précises sur la taxe
sur la l'exploitation des
infrastructures de transport de longue
distance est-ce que vous pourriez nous
préciser la répartition de la prévision
de recettes de 600 millions d'euros pour
2024 entre les différents types
d'exploitants autoroutes aéroport
en comparaison du montant des super des
surprofils autour de 4,6% ne peut-il pas
être qualifié de timide
l'article 4 permet d'assurer
l'application du pilier 2 de l'OCDE
visant restaurer un taux d'imposition
minimal des grandes entreprises pour
autant il prévoit d'appliquer la règle
des bénéfices insuffisamment à poser à
compter de 2025 seulement cela
signifie-t-il que certains entreprises
vont échapper à cette imposition
minimale troisième question dans son
rapport sur l'application des mesures
fiscales mon collègue Jean-René cases
dove indiquait qu'avec la prolongation
partielle en 2024 du bouclier tarifaire
une réflexion sur la prorogation de la
contribution sur la Renta marginale en
2024 serait justifiée à la lecture du
projet loi il me semble que vous avez
finalement décidé de ne pas reconstruire
reconduire cette contribution qu'elles
en sont les raisons
l'article 16 prévoit une réforme
d'ensemble des redevances perçues par
les agences de l'eau on comprend qu'il
s'agit de les rendre plus incitatives et
de financer les mesures du plan d'eau la
redevance sur la consommation d'eau
potable sera due par tous nos
concitoyens cette mesure va-t-elle se
traduire par une augmentation de la
facture
renchérissant toujours plus le prix des
mètres cubes d'eau nécessaire au premier
besoin qui devrait être gratuit
j'ai également une question sur
l'audiovisuel public au niveau de son
montant et le mode de financement est-ce
que vous comptez
renouveler reconduire le mécanisme qui a
été celui de l'an dernier et enfin j'ai
une dernière question mais qui était
induite par l'observation je vous ai
fait tout à l'heure
sur le chèque sans euros du chef de
l'État est-ce que vous êtes vraiment sûr
en fonction justement de l'inflation
persistante sur l'énergie que vous allez
pouvoir aller jusqu'au bout de cette fin
de du bouclier énergétique à ce jour et
une dernière réflexion amusante Bruno Le
Maire vous qui ne m'avez pas habitué à
la polémique je voudrais dire que
évoquer pour le blocage des prix l'URSS
c'est furieusement seventies alors
l'autre fois au dialogue de Bercy
m'avait parlé de de ne pas désespérer
Boulogne-Billancourt bon alors ça
renvoie peut-être d'ailleurs aux années
où le blocage des prix a eu lieu en
France et je vous rappelle qu'en dehors
du gouvernement bon roi de celui de Roca
il y a eu aussi celui du gouvernement au
bar et que c'était pas forcément l'URSS
dans ce pays voilà merci Monsieur le
rapport
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation vont peut-être quelques
remarques avant de vous poser un certain
nombre de questions première remarque
c'est que vous en avez parlé très
rapidement mais nous avons tenu nos
engagements pour 2023 malgré un contexte
économique internationale extrêmement
difficile et contraire malgré les
avertissements les oiseaux de mauvaise
augure très nombreux il y a un an sur
notre capacité à tenir nos engagements
de mes 23 nous l'avons fait et toutes
les hypothèses donc d'atterrissage pour
2023 le président de la Cour des comptes
là encore expliqué ce matin son
plausibles que ce soit en matière de
déficit en matière de dépenses en
matière d'inflation et en matière de de
croissance deuxième remarque c'est que
c'est un budget de responsabilité pour
notre majorité responsabilité d'abord
sur la trajectoire nous sommes engagés
avec la loi de programmation sur Red des
finances publiques jusqu'à 2027 à
hauteur de 2.7% de déficit ça passe par
4,4% de déficit en 2024 ça me paraît
être le minimum c'est un objectif que
nous devons absolument tenir pour garder
notre crédibilité vis-à-vis des marchés
et vis-à-vis de l'Europe deuxième raison
c'est un G2 responsabilité évidemment
sur la partie transition écologique
l'effort que nous faisons dans ce budget
et absolument unique exceptionnel nous
avons beaucoup travaillé avec des
instituts sur le chiffrage de ce qu'il
fallait faire pour respecter nos
objectifs nous avons beaucoup travaillé
sur la déclinaison secteur pasteur entre
les entreprises entre les collectivités
territoires entre l'État sur la manière
dont chacun devait porter sa part pour
atteindre ses objectifs et nous avons
dans la loi de programmation
effectivement côté la planification des
moyens sur lesquels l'État doit
s'engager pour atteindre cet objectif et
la marche que nous franchissons en 2024
nous paraît extrêmement importante et
s'inscrire dans cette lignée monsieur le
Président qui nous permettra d'atteindre
en 2027 l'objectif de du rapport
pisanique je ne vous parlerai pas très
rapidement de l'augmentation du fond
vert augmentation de les fonds de la
nain l'augmentation de ma prime rénove
l'extension du budget vert nous faisons
feu de tout bois c'est un budget en
matière d'écologie à 360 degrés et
troisième élément qui montre notre
responsabilité c'est que évidemment nous
avons un soutien particulier pour toutes
les politiques prioritaires que ce soit
l'éducation que ce soit le régalien avec
des augmentations pour 2024 extrêmement
importante et significative
deux points peut-être encore
revenir moi aussi sur le pilier 2 je
voudrais dire que c'est une grande
mesure et je pèse mes mots c'est une
grande mesure de justice fiscale je
pense qu'ici il y a quelques années
beaucoup on aurait rêvé cette ça
s'inscrit dans le travail qui a été fait
par notre gouvernement d'abord sur la
taxe dite Gafa pour lutter contre la
sous-imposition on va dire comme ça des
géants du numérique en France la France
a été moteur et la France a été moteur
également je voudrais saluer le rôle de
Bruno Le Maire en la matière pour cette
impôt minimale au niveau mondial
maintenant ça va être réel ça veut dire
que plus aucune entreprise
internationale multinationale ne pourra
payer dans aucun pays de l'OCDE
c'est-à-dire 130 ou 140 moins de 15%
d'impôts par état et par et par région
c'est une avancée extrêmement importante
de justice et puis autre mesure de
justice mais je vais pas m'étaler le
ministre Cazenave on a parlé beaucoup
c'est évidemment la lutte contre la
fraude qui est absolument essentielle
pour nous je cite la création d'une
peine d'indignité fiscale la création
d'un délit de mise à disposition de
moyens servant à frauder l'encadrement
observé des prix de transfert on revient
sur l'optimisation la sécurisation du
cadre d'intervention des agents etc etc
là aussi un budget extrêmement
sérieux copieux si vous me permettez
l'expression en matière de lutte contre
la fraude
j'ai quelques questions messieurs les
les ministres en prévoyant un déficit de
4,4% en 2024 vous engagez raisonnable en
France la France dans le la voie de la
maîtrise des finances publiques on en a
parlé donc conformément pas de stabilité
au projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques adopté par la
commission des finances il y a 48 heures
afin d'y parvenir malgré les aléasiales
à l'exécution budgétaire et les
incertitudes macroémies macroéconomique
pouvez-vous nous décrire les niveaux de
mise en réserve et les moyens de
régulation budgétaire que dont vous
envisagez l'usage afin de garantir
l'atteindre l'atteinte de ces objectifs
en 2024
vous nous présentez également un plan
d'émission de dette record de 285
milliards d'euros supérieur au montant
des années précédentes parce que
l'amortissement de notre dette pèse plus
lourd même si le déficit a financer
décroît nettement que pouvez-vous vous
dire les conditions d'emprunt actuel de
notre pays deuxième question dans le
paquet de verdissement de notre
fiscalité extrêmement significatif vient
de le dire vous proposer donc une
fiscalité à limite à l'immatriculation
des véhicules et des véhicules de
sociétés en particulier pour tenir
compte de
le coût écologique de l'intégralité de
la fabrication de ces voitures quel
rendement attendez-vous de cet axe et
pouvez-vous nous confirmer que 100% de
son produit sera réinjecté dans la
transition écologique et quand les
Français auront-ils l'information j'ai
envie de dire voiture par voiture de
pourront attendre comme type d'aide et
également
quand pouvez-vous nous dire que nous
serons en mesure de lancer le leasing à
100 euros par mois pour les voitures
électriques enfin dernière question sur
les nombreuses mesures de lutte contre
la fraude fiscale incluse dans ce texte
quels sont les objectifs chiffrés que
vous vous fixez en matière de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale dans les
prochaines années appuyez donc parler
évolutions législatives dont on parle et
quels sont les moyens humains nouveaux
dans le PLF 2024 puis les années
suivantes que vous comptez affecter à la
teinte de ces objectifs je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur messieurs
les ministres
merci monsieur le président
d'abord sur le pouvoir d'achat des plus
défavorisés je le redis
l'indexation de toutes les prestations
sociales et la meilleure des protections
qui est apportée aujourd'hui à tous ceux
de compatriotes qui sont les plus
touchés par l'inflation
je rappelle que sont indexés en France
le RSA les allocations familiales la
prime de rentrée scolaire le minimum
vieillesse la prime d'activité la
location adulte handicapé la location
Spécifique de Solidarité donc le filet
couvre très largement nos compatriotes
quand la sortie du bouclier sur le gaz
sur l'électricité je maintiens que c'est
une mesure juste à partir du moment où
les prix du gaz et les prix de
l'électricité baisse il n'y a aucune
raison de maintenir une protection
maximale
s'agissant des marges des entreprises je
rappelle que le Président de la
République a annoncé dimanche soir la
mise en place d'un accord de modération
des marges vous y travaillons avec les
industriels et les entreprises
concernées
s'agissant du financement de la
transition écologique là je pense que
c'est un débat qui est utile nous nous
ne contestons pas le montant global qui
peut être nécessaire à 60 à 70 milliards
d'euros par an mais nous contestons
formellement que l'intégralité de ce
financement doivent retomber sur les
épaules de l'État
il faut mobiliser les financements
privés nous l'avons fait qu'un certain
nombre d'instrument dans la loi
industrielle je constate que le taux
d'épargne des ménages a augmenté de 15 à
19% il n'a jamais été aussi élevé dans
notre pays depuis plusieurs décennies
mais c'est cette épargne là qu'il faut
mobiliser si nous mobilisons sans cesse
l'argent de l'État nous allons creuser à
nouveau les déficits et la dette
un mot sur le logement
c'est un enjeu immédiat et de long terme
absolument majeur pour nos compatriotes
et il faut bien noter que notre
politique du logement depuis plusieurs
décennies n'a absolument pas donné les
résultats escomptés
nous dépensons environ 1,5 points de
richesse nationale de plus que
l'Allemagne
à notre politique du logement avec des
résultats qui ne sont absolument pas la
hauteur de nos compatriotes qui ont du
mal à se loger et qui consacrent une
part très importante de leurs revenus au
logement
donc ça ne va pas il faut corriger et
c'est l'objectif de cette refondation du
politique du logement qui me paraît
indispensable nous devons refonder notre
politique du logement
pour refonder notre politique du
logement il faut d'abord qu'on soit
clair sur les objectifs on peut pas
poursuivre 50 objectifs à la fois pour
moi c'est ce qui explique que depuis
plusieurs décennies on se repars d'avoir
de bons résultats et ça peut faire
l'objet d'un beau débat politique est-ce
que l'objectif d'une politique du
logement c'est d'abord de garantir un
revenu supplémentaire un certain nombre
de compatriotes par l'immobilier locatif
si c'est ça l'objectif prioritaire il
faut multiplier les avantages fiscaux
comme c'est le cas depuis 10 ans ce qui
donne après une certaine notoriété au
ministre du Logement successif qui
veulent leur nom à coller à une loi le
problème de cette solution c'est qu'elle
est extraordinairement coûteuse le Pinel
c'était 2 milliards d'euros pour 30 000
logements par an
donc je ne trouve pas que ce soit
forcément très efficace mais on peut en
discuter pour moi l'objectif principal
d'une politique du logement c'est
construire rapidement des logements de
qualité dans les zones tendues et ça
doit être ce seul objectif qui devrait
nous guider mais ça doit faire
l'objectif ça doit faire l'objet
évidemment d'une discussion entre nous
troisième remarque est-ce qu'on peut
modifier immédiatement un certain nombre
de paramètres mais la réponse est oui
j'ai parfaitement conscience comme vous
monsieur le Président qu'il y a urgence
sur le logement et que donc il faut
corriger un certain nombre de paramètres
nous avions décidé de restreindre le
champ d'application du prêt à taux zéro
qui permet un certain nombre de
primo-accédants d'avoir une mise de
départ et donc d'avoir des crédits
immobiliers plus facilement
je suis tout à fait prêt à reconnaître
qu'aujourd'hui est augmentation des taux
la production de crédit immobilier a
chuté davantage que ce que nous avions
prévu je pense que c'est toujours bien
de reconnaître quand on n'a pas
nécessairement atteint son objectif pour
corriger plutôt que de santé donc je
suis prêt à revoir le barème du PTZ
pour qu'il puisse toucher un plus grand
nombre de nos compatriotes y compris des
classes moyennes et servir d'apport à
des ménages qui veulent acheter pour la
première fois et qui ont besoin
impérativement de ce prêt à taux zéro
je suis prêt également à réfléchir dans
le prolongement des propositions de
l'excellent président du groupe modem
Jean-Paul Mattei à la mise en place d'un
prêt à taux intermédiaire qui serait un
peu moins coûteux pour les finances
publiques mais un peu plus accessible
pour les classes moyennes avec un taux
de crédit aujourd'hui qui est à 4% est
évident que un prêt a-t-on intermédiaire
retrouve du sens tout à fait prêt à
travailler sur ce sujet là et nous avons
décidé dans les mesures immédiates que
sur les logements dit Airbnb l'avantage
fiscal devrait passer de 71 à 50% pour
libérer aussi un certain nombre de biens
immobiliers après il y a les réflexions
de moyens termes
là aussi je reprends certaines
propositions faites dans le rapport
sanguin maté qui est un rapport dans
lequel il y a plein d'idées certaines
que je partage d'autres que je ne
partage pas je dis pas qu'elles sont
bonnes ou qu'elles sont mauvaises je dis
juste que certaines je les partages et
d'autres je ne partage pas mais dans
celle que je trouve intéressante il y en
a beaucoup je vois qui est soulevé la
question de la fiscalité sur les
résidences secondaires on va oublier ce
terme de résidence secondaire qui est
impropre parce que c'est 4 millions de
logements et ça n'est pas que des villas
dans les endroits les plus côtés du
territoire français c'est des
appartements c'est des T2 c'est beaucoup
de bien immobilier aujourd'hui on est
une fiscalité qui permet l'exonération
de charges sociales
qui va de 22 jusqu'à 30 ans 1
les Red fiscales et sociales ne sont pas
alignés c'est pas très cohérent 2 elles
sont très éloignées 30 ans 3 la
conséquence de tout ça c'est que les
biens immobiliers circulent pas vous
proposez de réviser ces règles-là je
suis tout à fait prêt à engager le débat
avec vous regardez combien ça coûte
combien ça peut remettre de logements
sur le marché dans des délais rapides je
trouve que c'est une proposition très
intéressante autre proposition de moyen
terme qui très sensible je le sais mais
à laquelle je crois dont je vous donne
mes convictions sinon cette commission
des finances peut-être rébarbative il y
a des normes il y a des règles qui
méritent d'être simplifiées dans le
bâtiment
et je pense qu'on ne faut pas écarter
d'un revers de la main et faire de
toutes ces normes et de toutes ces
règles l'étape de la loi et les tables
du Prophète on doit pouvoir regarder un
salon de normes de règles de se dire bon
quand il y a pas de problème de logement
et peut-être tout à fait approprié mais
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut pas
suspendre l'application de certaines
modifier l'application de certaines
simplifier l'application de certaines je
n'ai pas la réponse immédiate je dis que
c'est un débat qui vaut le coup d'être
livré donc voilà sur la question du
logement en tout cas je partage monsieur
le Président votre inquiétude sur ce
sujet la nécessité d'agir d'agir vite
d'agir fort mais avec une perspective de
long terme puisque le logement c'est le
long terme qui doit être de construire
rapidement et des biens de qualité là où
les zones sont tendus
sur
les économies de 2025 je confirme ce
serait évidemment un débat entre nous
oui la marge 2025 est difficile il
faudra trouver 12 milliards d'euros
d'économies c'est pour ça que j'ai lancé
cet appel cet après-midi à tous les
députés en particulier de la majorité à
travailler avec moi deux choses les
revues de dépenses publiques qui vont
permettre de dégager des économies et
des transformations structurelles de la
place de l'État et de notre modèle
social en France pour arriver à
documenter ces 12 milliards d'euros
d'économies
un point d'accord avec vous c'est sur
l'impôt minimum à l'impôt sur le revenu
je pense que cela mérite d'être lancé au
niveau européen je rappelle que c'est la
France qui a lancé la taxation des Gafa
c'est la France qui a lancé cette
accession minimale à l'impôt chez
société et bien ça peut être la France
qui lance l'idée la taxeension minimale
à l'impôt sur le revenu avec tous ses
partenaires européens alors pourquoi en
européen plutôt qu'en français ben tout
simplement parce que nous ne voulons pas
qu'il y ait des départs de nos
compatriotes de territoires français par
une fiscalité qui serait plus
pénalisante en France que dans les
autres pays européens
sur la contribution sur la rente
inframarginale elle a été mise en place
par l'Union européenne en 2022 nous
n'avons immédiatement mis en place
reconduite en 2023 et elle s'éteint au
31 décembre 2023 si dans leur grande
sagesse des parlementaires souhaitent
prolonger la contribution sur les rente
infra marginales j'y suis ouvert et le
gouvernement y est ouvert dans une
période d'inflation persistante il me
paraît légitime il me paraît juste
d'ouvrir cette réflexion en tout cas je
l'accueille favorablement sur des
prévisions de croissance je rappelle que
la plante croissance de l'OCDE la
Commission à 1,2% celle du FMI 1,3% par
conséquent notre prévision à virgule 4
me paraît raisonnable les autres
prévisions de croissance ne tiennent pas
compte de l'effet sur notre croissance
de la réforme d'assurance chômage et de
la réforme des retraites
Jean-René Cazeneuve monsieur rapporteur
général du budget sur les conditions
d'emprunt actuels de notre pays en 2024
le besoin de financement de la France va
s'établir à 300 milliards d'euros
en baisse de 11 milliards d'euros
il sera principalement couvert par des
émissions nouvelles de dettes à moyen et
à long terme
ces émissions nouvelles de dettes
s'élèveront en 2024 à 285 milliards
d'euros
un chiffre qui est évidemment élevé mais
notre programme d'émission d'emprunt se
déroule sans difficulté en 2023
85% des émissions d'emprunt ont été
réalisées évidemment à des taux plus
élevés que par le passé en raison de la
politique monétaire de la BCE désormais
les taux d'émissions de ces emprunts
sont supérieurs à 3%. je précise enfin
sur ce sujet absolument majeur pour nos
finances publiques qui ne s'agit pas
d'une situation propre à la France et
que l'écart de taux avec l'Allemagne le
fameux spread sur nos obligations à 10
ans reste stable depuis le printemps
2022 autour de 50 à 60 points de base
cela montre la solidité de la politique
économique française
s'il y avait le moindre doute des
marchés sur notre capacité à financer
cette dette par notre croissance vous
auriez un spread sur les taux avec
l'Allemagne qui serait beaucoup plus
élevé il est stable à 50 à 60 points de
base depuis le printemps 2022 c'est pour
moi le meilleur indicateur de la
solidité de notre stratégie économique
cela ne m'interdit pas de rajouter et je
pense que vous partagerez cet avis que
lorsqu'on émet 285 milliards d'euros
d'emprunt pour 2024 il y a urgence à se
désendetter et à réduire la dépense
publique
dernière chose sur les bonus sur les
véhicules électriques nous donnerons
nous sommes encore en discussion avec la
ministre chargée de l'énergie et avant
arbitrage avec la Premier ministre je
peux juste vous confirmer que le montant
de ces bonus sur les véhicules
électriques augmentera en 2024 pour les
ménages modestes et pour les classes
moyennes et je vous confirme que les
premiers leasings à 100 euros pourront
être souscrits à partir de mi-novembre
de cette année
enfin tout dernier point peut-être même
si c'est plus de la politique
industrielle que de la politique
budgétaire je rappelle que pour la
première fois les bonus sur les
véhicules électriques seront réservés à
des véhicules qui remplissent un certain
nombre d'obligations environnementales
et qui respectent les meilleurs normes
environnementales de la planète c'est à
dire principalement des véhicules
européens et je pense que c'est très
important qu'on puisse dire à nos
compatriotes depuis cette salle la
commission des finances que désormais le
1,2 milliards d'euros de bonus véhicules
électriques sont payés par le
contribuable vont à des véhicules
européens qui respectent les meilleurs
normes environnementales il y avait
quelque chose d'assez incohérent à
donner des bonus environnementaux à des
véhicules produits dans des conditions
environnementales qui n'étaient pas
satisfaisantes voire dégradée et je
suggère vivement que nous poursuivions
dans cette voie là dans les mois à venir
pour définir ce que j'appelle un contenu
industriel européen aux aides qui sont
apportées à l'industrie
merci monsieur le Président j'aurais dû
commencer par là avant ma première
intervention pour vous dire que je
souhaitais respecter une tradition à la
commission des finances et que j'ai donc
amené une spécialité de du territoire
qui est cher à mon cœur serait pas
surpris il s'agit des cannelés qui
doivent quelque part être à l'entrée qui
vous sera fin à la fois
non ça sera pas du vin
bon j'en reviens quand même à vos
questions monsieur le Président je
voulais pas distraire complètement la
commission des finances
c'est raté ça fait une petite
respiration cela dit bon sur les sujets
les questions je voulais revenir
notamment sur monsieur monsieur le
président
je vois qu'on a disciplet
on a dissipé
pas le reproche monsieur le président
sur le financement de la transition
écologique
on peut pas comparer les 7 milliards de
l'État aux 30 ou 35 milliards de la part
publique du rapport de Jean Pisani ferry
le financement public de la transition
écologique ce n'est pas que l'Etat c'est
les collectivités territoriales c'est un
certain nombre de dispositifs laissez la
responsabilité l'argile producteur on a
un ensemble de dispositifs à remettre en
perspective et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense que la la trajectoire
pluriannuelle sur le financement de la
transition écologique nous permettra d'y
voir plus clair et d'avoir un débat je
trouve plus éclairé sur ce sujet là sur
la question des plus riches quand même
monsieur Coquerel qui ne contribuerait
pas assez je voulais juste attirer
l'attention sur un point nous avons
indexé le barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu à l'exception de la contribution
sur les hauts revenus
à l'exception de la contribution sur les
revenus qui sont déjà largement mis à
contribution et je le dis c'est
probablement il faut commander en détail
vraiment plus d'un milliard d'euros donc
ne dites pas ne dites pas qu'on leur
demande pas un effort supplémentaire ce
n'est pas vrai sur votre question sur la
taxe sur les infrastructures et
gestionnaire d'infrastructures elle se
répartirait fonction de la situation
financière entre 500 millions pour les
sociétés d'autoroute et 100 millions
d'euros pour les aéroports sur la
question de la question sur la réforme
de la redevance sur la consommation
d'eau potable vous savez que dans le
cadre des Assises de l'eau nous avons
proposé c'est l'article 16 du PLF une
réforme très importante
des redevances en fait de plusieurs
redevances les actuelles redevances pour
pollution d'origine domestique et pour
modernisation des réseaux de collègues
vont être remplacés par une nouvelle
redevance sur la consommation d'eau
potable qui va concerner aussi bien les
particuliers que les entreprises mais
vous avez aussi les redevances pour la
performance des réseaux d'eau potable
d'une part et des systèmes collectif
d'autre part afin d'inciter à la
diminution des fuites et à
l'amélioration du traitement et enfin la
redevance pour prélèvement elle est
réformée selon du principe du préleveur
payeur avec un rendement d'à peu près
132 millions d'euros entre le secteur de
l'énergie 100 millions d'euros de
l'agriculture 10 millions d'euros et
l'industrie 30 millions d'euros cette
réforme elle rééquilibre les efforts
entre les ménages et les autres
consommateurs d'eau
la réforme proposée elle est donc neutre
pour les ménages et les comités de
bassin pourront ensuite s'en emparer en
2024 pour ajuster leur tarification en
fonction des besoins du plan o et enfin
nous travaillons avec les collectivités
pour leur permettre de mettre en place
une tarification sociale de l'eau
puisque c'est un sujet sur lesquels elle
souhaite pouvoir avancer sur la question
de Jean-René Cazeneuve sur la mise en
réserve et les moyens de régulation sont
des dispositifs très importants pour
nous dès 2024 on va augmenter le taux de
mise en réserve en le passant de 3,5 à
4%. et je rappelle que ce taux de mise
en réserve ne s'applique ni aux dépenses
de personnel naturellement ni aux
dépenses de prestations sociales nous
gèlerons ainsi 9,4 milliards d'euros de
crédit de paiement au début de l'année
on pourra en cours d'année 2024 utiliser
d'autres moyens de régulation vous le
savez certains des dispositifs qu'on a
utilisés en 2023 j'en cite un en
particulier le surgel des crédits qui a
eu lieu en courant d’année sur 1% des
crédits qui est permis de mettre en
réserve 1 milliards d'euros et je le dis
dans le prolongement du surgel ça nous
avait permis d'annuler un décret que
nous avons pris très récemment 5
milliards d'euros de crédit sur le
périmètre du ministère de l'économie et
des finances pour s'assurer que ces
crédits n'étaient pas recyclés vers
d'autres dépenses et tenir notre
trajectoire 2023
sur les objectifs chiffrés notamment en
matière de lutte contre la fraude vous
avez raison d'insister sur le fait que
ce projet de loi de finance il apporte
des évolutions très significatives pour
en améliorer l'efficacité nous ne fixons
en fait jamais d'objectifs parce qu'ils
sont difficiles à fixer nous allons
installer un comité d'évaluation des
fraudes le 10 octobre avec des
spécialistes des universitaires des
experts pour mieux chiffrer le montant
de la fraude fiscale et sociale mais un
point quand on la dernière loi froide
elle nous avait permis d'augmenter les
droits recouvrés de 9 milliards 11
milliards donc on est confiant sur le
fait que le renforcement de l'arsenal
nous permettra d'améliorer notre
performance en la matière et enfin les
moyens
1500 et TP supplémentaires dans les
services du contrôle fiscal à Bercy avec
déjà une première marche dès 2024 de 250
emplois supplémentaires mais également
le doublement des effectifs d'officiers
fiscaux judiciaire dans le cas de la
transformation du service d'enquête
judiciaire fiscale enace et puis nous
allons par parallélisme renforcer les
effectifs dans le champ du contrôle de
la lutte de la lutte contre la fraude
sociale à hauteur de 1000 TP dans les
caisses de sécurité sociale on n'est pas
en train de débattre du PLFSS mais je
pense que c'est important de voir la
cohérence d'ensemble de notre politique
en la matière
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc en même
temps que la libération des cannelés on
va passer aux orateurs de groupe 2
minutes chacun en commençant par
Renaissance Mathieu Lefebvre merci
monsieur le Président et merci messieurs
les ministres pour la présentation de ce
budget qui est fait de choix forts et
qui assume le sérieux dans le fond comme
seul antidote à la double impasse du
laxisme et de et de l'austérité d'abord
il assume de poursuivre une politique
économique qui marche les ministres
l'ont rappelé mais nous avons créé 2
millions d'emplois depuis 2017
et nous n'avons pas vocation à changer
une politique économique qui gagne le
plein emploi à un prix et ce prix c'est
la constance de notre politique
économique et fiscale il assume aussi la
fin de l'endettement du crise nous avons
protégé les Français comme aucun autre
pays et nous avons évité de passer par
la case récession cependant à cet
endroit endettement de crise il est
aujourd'hui incompatible avec la
préservation de notre souveraineté
européenne quand on sait la divergence
d'endettement dans la zone euro ainsi
que nous la rappeler le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques et au fond on peut
pas s'armer de cette divergence et
réclamer des mesures dispendieuses
supplémentaires il assume aussi de
refuser la double impasse des impôts et
de la dette l'un allant hélas trop
souvent avec l'autre il assume également
de réduire les dépenses inefficaces pour
mettre le paquet sur les dépenses
d'avenir et de sécurité on rentrera dans
le détail mais c'est un budget
historique pour l'école c'est un budget
historique pour la protection de nos
concitoyens et c'est un budget
historique pour la transition écologique
il assume également le ministre cazena
va parler de bouclier c'est un véritable
bouclier social qui est mise en oeuvre
avec l'indexation des retraites des
prestations sociales et dans l'impôt sur
le revenu le tout pour un point de PIB
25 milliards d'euros c'est un effort
absolument considérable et il assume
tout en défendant l'idée qu'il faut
partager le fardeau de l'inflation
considérant que l'état non seulement ne
peut pas tout mais ne doit pas tout
parce que l'État mes chers collègues
c'est vous c'est moi et à la fin c'est
le contribuable qui doit payer enfin il
assume de mener des combats en européen
c'est ce qu'a fait le ministre Bruno Le
Maire avec notamment la question de
l'imposition pilier 2 ce combat si nous
n'avions pas mené en européen il ne
serait pas arrivé à son terme et nous
n'aurions pas aujourd'hui son résultat
dans ce projet de loi de finance j'ai
une question sur le crédit d'impôt
industriel mais tu as les ministres nous
sommes aussi la majorité à qui conjugue
industrie et écologie c'est un crédit
d'impôt extrêmement important qui va
permettre 23 milliards d'euros
d'investissement supplémentaires dans
notre pays est-ce que vous pourriez nous
détailler messieurs les ministres
comment se vantile cette répartition
entre les différentes filières d'avenir
qui sont concernés merci Jean-Philippe
Tanguy pour l'Assemblée nationale
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre écoutez 50 ans en 2024 ce sera
la 50e année que la France n'a pas de
budget à l'équilibre je ne parle même
pas évidemment d'excédent faut pas rêver
donc 50 ans normalement quand on s'aime
c'est les noces d'or et avec vous à vous
écouter c'est les noces de plomb voilà
ça fait 50 ans 50 ans que l'arc de la
raison du haut de sa prétention de
compétences plombe les finances de la
France accumulent de la dette multiplie
les impôts et ne sait plus contrôler les
dépenses je ne suggestion Monsieur le
Maire pour vous de nouveau roman pour
vos soirées d'hiver je vous pourriez
réécrire le mythe des tonneaux des
denaides ou du rocher de Sisyphe et
réinventer vous êtes une sorte
d'incarnation de l'effort inutile de
d'une malédiction qui fait que quand
vous prétendez depuis six ans
redécouvrir chaque année la trajectoire
saine des finances publiques chaque
année vous remettez la France vers plus
de tête vers plus d'endettement vous
êtes débordé par la situation l'année
dernière je vous avais dit monsieur le
ministre que vous étiez comme un
capitaine d'un radeau pris dans la
tempête de l'hyperinflation sans voile
sans gouvernail ne sachant pas où il
allait maintenant la tempête se calme
vous découvrez l'état de votre radeau et
vous écopez vous écopez à la petite
semaine en essayant de réduire par-ci
par la quelques dépenses mais vous
n'êtes même pas capable de sortir l'eau
de l'eau qui a débordé de votre plan
contre
l'hyperinflation et donc vous ne
réduisez même pas des finances des
dépenses exceptionnelles une situation
qui selon vos termes est redevenu normal
donc en fait c'est assez cohérent en
fait l'exception avec vous et la règle à
savoir que le désordre économique le
désordre fiscal est systématiquement la
règle monsieur Macron a de la chance
puisque depuis dimanche on sait que
c'est Monsieur Bricolage à l'Élysée et
il a trouvé de bons artisans à Bercy
pour trouver des expédiants essayer de
mener ses travaux trouver 3 centimes par
ci quelques euros par là et à la fin on
aura 2027 un record du coup de
l'endettement donc moi je n'ai pas
beaucoup de questions finalement à vous
poser bah oui face à un tel désastre ma
seule question c'est est-ce que vous
allez faire perdre beaucoup de temps au
Parlement ou est-ce que vous allez
assumer de passer directement en 49,3 ce
qui me permettra de passer sans doute à
des textes plus intéressant comme
l'immigration qui est l'arlésienne de
votre mandat
Emmanuel Bompard pour la France
insoumise oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur les ministres vous
nous présenter aujourd'hui un budget en
nous disant que son défi premier et de
lutter contre l'inflation mais pour
lutter contre un mal il faut d'abord en
comprendre les ressorts le Fond
Monétaire International nous dit
aujourd'hui à l'échelle mondiale que
plus de la moitié de l'inflation est dû
à l'augmentation des profits des grandes
entreprises mais rien dans ce que vous
nous proposez dans ce budget rien dans
votre action ne permet de casser cette
boucle entre les prix et les profits
vous prétendez monsieur le ministre le
maire avoir obtenu des avancées
historiques je pense qu'il suffit
d'aller faire ses courses ou d'aller
faire son plein pour voir à quel point
vous n'avez rien obtenu du tout et la
seule chose historique qui s'est
déroulée l'année dernière c'est le
record historique de versement des
dividendes des grandes entreprises et
les résultats historiques qui ont été
faits par un certain nombre de
profiteurs de dans votre discussion tout
à l'heure vous écartez avec ironie et
mauvaise foi des mesures de contraintes
vis-à-vis des industriels j'ai été ravi
d'apprendre que vous avez que vous êtes
donc ministre de l'Union soviétique
puisque il y a quelques semaines de ça
vous avez décidé de bloquer le prix de
vente de bouteilles d'eau à Mayotte sans
que ça ne produise les pénuries dont
vous venez de parler quant à faire
croire que des mesures de blocage des
prix reposeraient sur nos agriculteurs
ça en serait presque risible si c'est
pas dramatique puisque 70% les marges de
l'agroalimentaire ont augmenté en deux
ans de 70% et ce donc bien sur ça qu'il
faut attaquer mais vous refusez toutes
ces mesures contraignantes et vous
préférez distribuer un mini chèque qui
va permettre au maximum de faire un
plein
d'essence dans l'année bref vous
abandonnez encore une fois les Français
qui sont condamnés à continuer à
alimenter les profits des grandes
entreprises vous avez demandé tout à
l'heure des vous avez dit que les
oppositions ne proposaient pas de
recette donc je vais en faire ici
et je vous demande de les noter puisque
à chaque fois vous dites vous ne faites
pas de proposition de recettes donc si
vous pouvez les noter s'il vous plaît
nouveau proposons de rétablir l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune nous vous
proposons de mettre en place une
véritable taxe sur les super profits
nous vous proposons de remettre en cause
la suppression de la CVAE qui va encore
coûter plusieurs milliards d'euros au
finance publique et nous vous proposons
d'introduire enfin comme la demande et
le Haut Conseil pour le climat un
conditionnement social et écologique des
200 milliards
publics accordées par l'État aux
entreprises voilà des propositions de
recettes est-ce que vous comptez y
donner suite merci Véronique clouvegie
pour les républicains oui merci monsieur
le Président merci Monsieur les
ministres pour cette présentation merci
Monsieur le Ministre Thomas Cazenave
pour les gourmandises que vous nous avez
apporté de Bordeaux deux remarques qui
sont des regrets avant de passer aux
questions un premier regret puisque vous
nous avez parlé finalement de vouloir
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux Français
c'est une ministre pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux Français il faut
diminuer les prélèvements obligatoires
ce que vous ne faites aucunement parce
que finalement ce sont ces prélèvements
obligatoires aujourd'hui qui pénalisent
le ménage les entreprises j'en veux pour
preuve la croissance spontanée de 3% que
vous inscrivez au niveau des
prélèvements obligatoires qui nous les
mettrons à 1241 milliards un deuxième
regret également sur les dépenses vous
nous présentez effectivement monsieur le
ministre cazena vous avez parlé d'une
baisse historique des dépenses mais en
fait dans cette best historique des
dépenses de 16 milliards il n'y a pas de
diminution des dépenses structurelles
d'ailleurs preuve en est vous parlez
tout de suite de 2025 parce
qu'effectivement vous aurez une
difficulté en 2025 et c'est un regret
que nous avons une première question et
j'invite tous mes collègues à se joindre
à moi le gouvernement publie depuis
quelques temps l'ensemble des avis
rendus par le Conseil d'État sur
l'ensemble des projets de loi sauf pour
les textes financiers j'avais déposé un
amendement 2021 lors de la révision de
la Golf j'invite d'ailleurs le président
de la commission des finances à se
joindre à cette demande mais si le
ministre est-ce que vous acceptez de
publier les avis des conseils d'État sur
les textes financiers évidemment votre
refus contribue ne contribuerait pas à
limiter les échanges que vous appelez de
vos vœux une première question sur
l'hypothèse de croissance vous évoquez
une hypothèse de croissance d'un virgule
quatre pour cent la Banque de France
retient un taux de croissance de 0,9
points quel serait l'impact en termes de
déficit de cet écart de croissance une
deuxième question sur l'hypothèse de
baisse du taux d'épargne de
0,4% que vous intégrez dans ce PLF il
semblerait que toutes les hypothèses
ayant un impact favorable sur ce niveau
d'épargne devrait converger dans le même
sens est-ce que véritablement nous
pouvons être sûr de cette situation et
une dernière question qui concerne
l'article 7 qui prévoit la création d'un
nouveau dispositif France rural
revitalisation un dispositif qui va
prendre le relais derrière les zonage
notamment ZRR est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner les impacts et la liste des
communes avec l'Impact pour l'ensemble
de ces communes je vous remercie
merci
Marina Ferrari pour le groupe démocrate
merci merci président la skate terrible
quand on passe en dernier c'est que
beaucoup de choses ont été dit mais ça
me permettra d'enfoncer le clou alors
messieurs les ministres sur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
n'en déplaisent à celles et ceux qui
voudraient nous faire croire que ce PLF
est un PLF d'austérité ce budget est
avant tout un budget déterminé et
équilibré déterminer à soutenir nos
concitoyens face à l'inflation
déterminés à poursuivre notre politique
de soutien à l'économie qui continue de
porter ses fruits déterminer à rétablir
l'état dans ses missions régaliennes
santé éducation justice sécurité défense
déterminée à soutenir l'investissement
public qui est le moteur de notre
croissance déterminé à réduire notre
endettement et notre déficit public qui
est une responsabilité morale impérieuse
vis-à-vis des générations futures et qui
est vous le savez une responsabilité
chère à notre famille politique
déterminée enfin accélérer notre
transition écologique et énergétique
cruciale pour notre avenir ce budget est
également équilibré puisqu'il repose à
la fois sur des économies et sur un
recentrage et une augmentation de nos
dépenses publiques sur les actions
prioritaires pour réussir devons
cependant aller plus loin en matière de
responsabilité en accélérant la revue
des dépenses publiques en concertation
étroite entre l'État les collectivités
et les organismes de sécurité sociale en
matière de santé la prévention devra
être au coeur de notre action il nous
faut également adapter notre fiscalité
au nouveau contexte en ce sens la
transposition de l'accord OCDE sur
l'imposition minimale des grandes
entreprises qui t'inscrit dans le texte
est historique le gouvernement est-il
prêt à poursuivre cette adaptation de
notre fiscalité enfin ce budget devrait
de notre point de vue permettre
d'apporter des premières réponses à la
crise du logement sans pour autant
prétendre la résoudre nous regrettons la
réduction d'ambition du PTZ et nous
aurons des propositions en la matière de
plus au-delà du sujet des plateformes
qui fait couler beaucoup d'entes et qui
n'est qu'une toute petite partie du
sujet est-ce que le gouvernement est
prêt à travailler sur une réforme
systémique pour le logement sur la
question des plus-values immobilières ou
sur la création d'un véritable statut de
l'investisseur immobilier que nous
appelons de nos vœux je vous remercie
merci
Christine piresburn pour le groupe
socialiste
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs les ministres pour votre
présentation
monsieur le ministre le maire un recul
de l'inflation ça signifie quand même de
l'inflation 5,2 en 2022 4,9 en 2023 soit
en deux ans plus de 10 % et j'ajoute que
les bolcheviques du FMI écrivent que la
moitié de l'inflation est due à
l'avidité des entreprises alors je vous
le dis les Français se moquent de savoir
si nos voisins ont moins d'inflation ce
qu'ils veulent c'est manger à leur faim
et vivre de leur travail ou de leur
retraite ce qui n'est pas le cas et je
ne vois pas dans ce PLF les mesures du
pouvoir de vivre j'en viens à quelques
questions et de remerciement merci car
j'ai entendu monsieur Cazeneuve que
l'expérimentation du dispositif des
avisor fiscaux pour les montants les
manquements supérieurs à 100.000 euros
seraient pérennisé et que les enquêteurs
pourraient travailler sous alias
confirmez-vous que j'ai bien entendu
mais aussi merci Monsieur le Maire car
j'ai entendu une ouverture dans le PTZ
mais êtes-vous prêt à revenir sur le
zonage absurde entre zones tendues et
détendue dans certains cas et
pouvons-nous avancer réellement pour que
les logements nus soient traités à
minima comme des logements meublés en
harmonisant les taux de fiscalité mais
aussi les plafonds
sur les économies l'opposition me ferait
pas de proposition nous en faisons et
depuis longtemps monsieur le ministre
sur les niches fiscales sur les niches
sociales et sur la base de rapport et
d'expertise sérieuse puisqu'ils émanent
de France stratégie de la Cour des
comptes du CAE encore faut-il nous
entendre un exemple passé en 8 ans de 2
à 7 milliards de dépenses avec le crédit
d'impôt recherche sans vouloir plafonner
et irresponsable quand on est ministre
du Budget surtout quand l'efficience
n'est pas toujours au rendez-vous autre
point j'ai remis un rapport comme vous
le savez Messieurs les ministres sur le
reste à charge en EHPAD où je documente
précisément le constat suivant
76% des résidents n'ont pas de revenus
mensuels suffisants pour payer leur gîte
et leur couverts en EHPAD c'est honteux
c'est inadmissible et j'aurais
évidemment des propositions
issues de ce rapport pour Camille Nima
les classes populaires et les classes
moyennes puissent être aidés je vous
remercie
merci lise manier pour le groupe horizon
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs les ministres pour votre
présentation de ce PLF 2024 alors notre
groupe évidemment partage pleinement les
priorités de ce budget la poursuite de
l'investissement dans la transition
écologique et le renforcement
substantiel des crédits à louer au
ministère régalien et à l'éducation
nationale tout en respectant la
trajectoire de rétablissement des
finances publiques alors nous n'avons
bien sûr pas encore eu le temps
d'examiner le texte en détail mais je
veux souligner quelques articles qui me
paraissent particulièrement intéressant
d'abord l'article 2 qui permet
l'indexation du barème de lierre sur
l'inflation pour protéger les Français
et ainsi permettre aux Français qui
travaillent de ne pas voir leurs impôts
à augmenter je citerai également
l'article 5 qui crée le crédit d'impôt
au titre des investissements faveur de
l'industrie verte on y voit là un
excellent signal envoyé pour la
réindustrialisation de la France via
l'industrie verte ou encore l'article 4
qui transporte qui trans de l'accord
mondial sur la position minimum des
multinationales c'est une grande avancée
pour plus de justice fiscale et une
meilleure fiscalisation des grands
groupes et je sais que nous vous devons
beaucoup monsieur le ministre le maire
sur ce sujet ma première question
d'ailleurs concerne cet article 4
messieurs les ministres pouvez-vous nous
confirmer que les coopératives agricoles
françaises n'entre pas dans le champ
d'application de cet article ma deuxième
question porte sur l'article 14 qui
prévoit le renforcement de la fiscalité
applicable au véhicule selon leur niveau
de pollution je n'ai pas lu ou pas vu
peut-être
en revanche un renforcement des aides à
la conversion ou des mesures semblables
pour aider les Français effectivement
dans le changement de leur véhicule
enfin ma dernière question monsieur les
ministres portent sur le prélèvement sur
recettes au profit de l'Union européenne
fixée à un peu plus de 21 milliards
d'euros pour 2024 contre près de 25
milliards d'euros en 2023 est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer cette baisse
substantielle je vous remercie merci
Charles de course pour non pardon
excusez-moi Nicolas donc Christine
Arrighi décidément si je m'en prends la
nuit pêche ça va pas du tout Cristina
régie pour le groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le Président après ces
hésitations messieurs les ministres
alors ce projet de loi de finances
arrive dans un contexte particulièrement
tendu tendue pour nos concitoyens et
surtout les plus précaires qui subissent
de plein fouet l'impact de l'inflation
ainsi que les effets du réchauffement
climatique tendus pour nos collectivités
territoriales devenues de toute évidence
la variable d'ajustement du gouvernement
alors du rapide examen du projet de loi
de finance qui nous a été communiqué ce
matin pour une discussion cet après-midi
il apparaît qu'après la valse des
milliards et des millions qui ont saturé
l'espace médiatique depuis plus de six
mois nous voici confrontés à la vérité
des prix et de vos engagements réels et
là c'est le conteniez pas ni pour la
planification écologique ni pour le
soutien des plus précaires face au
ravage l'inflation pas davantage pour
les collectivités alors deux exemples
l'annonce présidentielle d'un grand plan
de rénovation des écoles par un
abondement de 500 millions
d'autorisations d'engagement pas de
crédit de paiement mais autorisation
d'engagement sur le fond vert avec un
objectif de 2000 écoles rénovées dès
2024 pour répondre au Cap collectif de
41000 établissements rénovés en disant
or savez-vous monsieur le ministre
combien coûte la rénovation du groupe
scolaire Rangueil sur ma circonscription
12 millions d'euros
et celle d'une plus petite école qui
s'appelle Paul Bert comme ça vous
pourrez vérifier 2 millions 300000 euros
autre exemple toujours sur la base d'une
parole présidentielle du mois de
décembre 2020 celui d'un engagement fort
de l'État pour le développement des
services express régionaux métropolitain
une évaluation de la SNCF et des
collectivités terroriales portent ses
opérations un milliard par opération à
ce jour devait être débloqué 800
millions pour des études dans le cadre
des CPER dont nous découvrons
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont été ramenés à 700
17 échappés on ne sait pas où
alors le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques c'est montrer particulièrement
prudent s'agissant de vos évaluations et
il avait raison visiblement vous avez de
nouveau raté le coche des solutions
existent pourtant pour ramener le
déficit public au niveau des exigences
européennes mettez en place des mesures
d'économies structurelle tels que la fin
des niches fiscales néfaste au climat
arrêter les soutiens au projet d'énergie
fossile et à l'échelle européenne
sortait durant même temps et n'empêchait
pas ce que vous venez de faire
exactement en ce moment un durcissement
des normes de population de pollution
sur les gaz d'échappement des voitures
particulières merci Nicolas sangsue pour
le groupe GDR
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres à écouter vos propos je ne
comprends pas la gratitude des Français
qui affiche au mieux leur scepticisme au
pire leur hostilité et pourtant nos
compatriotes ont bien raison le pouvoir
d'achat le pouvoir de vivre est en berne
pour trop de nos concitoyens
particulièrement des couches modestes et
moyennes une étude vient de confirmer
que le salaire moyen aura perdu en trois
ans 0,5% de pouvoir d'achat que les
retraites du régime général auront perdu
2,7% en 3 ans et le RSA il est
prestations familiales auront perdu
3,2%. alors vous pouvez vous délivrer
des brevets d'auto-satisfaction tenter
plus nos concitoyens n'en peuvent plus
de l'énergie cher des prix des dents
alimentaires qui flambent d'un prix à la
pompe qui ne cesse de monter or dans les
mesures de votre projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 rien ne vient
réellement et concrètement
contrebalancer cette spirale de perte de
pouvoir d'achat
rappelez-vous d'ailleurs en prenant
juste la mesure sur l'essence que pour
2023 vous aviez proposé de faire 300
euros pour les trois premiers des cils
200 euros pour les deux premiers défis
et aujourd'hui vous vous contentez de
100 euros pour tout le monde pour les
celles et ceux qui travaillent comme si
les retraits qui emmenaient leurs
petits-enfants à l'école ou au sport
n'avaient pas droit à cette mesure nous
aurons bien entendu si la fièvre du PLF
n'atteint pas trop vite 49 degrés 3 des
propositions pour une architecture
fiscale qui remettent plus de
progressivité qui a soit des
prélèvements sur les richesses
indécentes comme cela a été démontré par
le rapport que nous avons commis
conjointement avec Jean-Paul Mattei nous
porterons des propositions en ce sens
pour favoriser notamment les
investissements permettant de répondre à
l'urgence climatique et il n'est pas
entendable que l'on nous répète
l'ancienne de la stabilité des
dispositifs fiscaux pour refuser de
prendre en compte des réalités qui
bougent il n'y a pas de consentement à
l'impôt si l'esprit la lettre de
l'article 13 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et des citoyens sur
les contributions en selon les facultés
respectives ne sont pas respectées et
c'est cela j'ai pour finir trois
remarques précises sur le logement vous
avez dit beaucoup de choses mais j'ai
une question très précise l'extinction
du Pinel sera-t-il redéployée pour
préserver et étendre le PTZ 2 dans le
cadre de la transition écologique et
pour favoriser les mobilités douces ne
ressent-ils pas ne serait-il pas
opportun de permettre un accroissement
du versement mobilité comme cela sans
envoyer de le cas pour le STIF et enfin
pour les agences de l'eau au-delà de la
réforme des redevances prenez-vous
l'engagement de ne pas divertir une part
des ressources vers le budget général
merci Charles de Courson pour le groupe
piote
trois petites questions mais c'est les
ministres première question est-ce que
vous partagez la vie du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques selon lequel vos
prévisions sont optimistes et que la
probabilité que toutes vos provisions se
réalisent et faibles
deuxième question
d'après le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques la croissance des dépenses
publiques hors dépenses liées à la crise
sanitaire et au coût des mesures liées à
l'inflation et aux dépenses de relance
est estimée en 2023 à 5,4% en valeur et
0,5 % en volume et non pas en baisse
alors que la croissance du PIB et de
l'ordre de 1% en volume et en 2024
d'après le Haut Conseil la hausse est de
4,8% en valeur et de 2,2% en volume soit
beaucoup plus que la croissance du Pitt
estimée que vous estimez à
1,4%. et pensez-vous qu'une telle
croissance est compatible avec le
redressement des finances publiques et
puis dernière question
où sont les économies dans le projet de
loi de finances pour 2024 et pourquoi
repoussez-vous à 2025 les 12 milliards
d'économies dont personne ne connaît le
contenu
messieurs les ministres
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
sur je reviens pas sur les propos de
Mathieu Lefebvre que je remercie de son
appréciation sur la politique économique
du gouvernement qui fonctionne
que je partage
un mot simplement sur le Crédit Impôt
industrie verte
nous sommes je le redis le premier étage
européen à mettre en place un crédit
d'impôt sur le modèle de une fashion Act
mise en place par Monsieur Biden aux
États-Unis
nous sommes à un moment géopolitique où
toutes les chaînes de valeur sont en
cours de réorganisation
c'est le moment d'investir sur
l'industrie verte
et nous ne ferons venir à nous les
usines de batterie électrique Danone
etcode d'hydrogène vert de pales
d'éolienne ou de panneaux solaires
panneaux photovoltaïques que si nous
offrons des conditions parmi les plus
attractives nous sommes déjà sur
l'occasion d'y revenir en réponse aux
remarques de Monsieur Tanguy la nation
la plus attractive en Europe pour les
investissements étrangers en rajoutant
ce qu'est d'impôts nous doublons les
chances d'avoir des investisseurs qui
viennent en France ouvrir des usines et
des postes d'ouvriers ces crédits
d'impôts industriels doivent financer
une soixantaine de projets à hauteur de
23 milliards d'euros d'investissements
total en France
ce crédit d'impôts représente un coup de
3,7 milliards coût budgétaire direct
d'ici 2030
2,5 milliards d'euros pour les batteries
électriques voyez bien que dans le nord
de la France notamment dans la région du
Dunkerquois nous sommes en train de
créer un des plus grands pôles européens
de batterie électrique 500 millions
d'euros sur les panneaux photovoltaïques
500 millions d'euros sur l'éolien et 100
millions d'euros chez pompe à chaleur
même si cela montera en puissance à la
suite des annonces du président de la
République l'objectif est bien à partir
de maintenant de développer les
nouvelles filières industrielles liées à
l'industrie verte je pense que nous
avons aujourd'hui tous les atouts de
l'autre côté
monsieur Tanguy sur le fait que nous
n'ayons pas de budget à l'équilibre je
vous répondrai que ce ne sera
certainement pas grâce à vos
propositions que nous y parviendrons
puisque toutes les propositions du
rassemblement national ne font que
creuser davantage les dépenses publiques
et les déficits vous proposez de
supprimer la TVA sur les carburants des
milliards d'euros vous proposez
d'abaisser l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite 20 milliards d'euros vous
proposez d'exonérer d'impôts les jeunes
ça représente suivant le calibrage que
l'on retient de la mesure de l'ordre de
10 milliards d'euros j'en suis déjà à 40
milliards d'euros de dépenses donc vous
faites couler un peu plus vite le bateau
et vous ne garantissez certainement pas
un retour à l'équilibre quant au mot de
radeau que vous employez pour décrire la
France c'est un mot qui ne me convient
pas pour moi la France est davantage un
paquebot solide puissant qu'un radeau
mais je vous laisse la paternité de ce
terme je rappelle que en France nous
approchons du plein emploi que en France
vont créer des millions d'emplois que en
France nous avons ouvert 300 usines et
si le paquebot était si peu attirant que
cela il ne serait pas devenu celui sur
lequel tous les investisseurs étrangers
veulent s'embarquer en priorité
aujourd'hui
je réponds à votre remarque comme à
celle que fait madame piresboun vous
n'avez pas lu attentivement le rapport
du FMI
parce que le rapport du FMI il indique
que l'inflation vient des profits en
zone euro à l'exception de la France
et c'est étonnant comme vous disiez
qu'une partie du rapport
justement en France la répartition
capitale travaille c'est une des grandes
caractéristiques de la France et elle
est restée stable au cours des années
passées
et quand il y a eu des profits nous
aviez indiqué sur généticien qui était
nécessaire de capter cette rente nous
l'avons fait
le résultat c'est que le FMI établit
très clairement que ce qui nourrit
l'inflation dans certains pays
développés mais ça ne le fait pas en
France précisément en raison notre
politique redistributive quand à vos
propositions savoir que je lui donnerai
suite je préfère très calme et vous tout
de suite que ce soit sur le
rétablissement de l'ISF le renoncement à
baisse d'un pot de production ou le
renoncement à la suppression de la CVAE
cette majorité ne donnera pas suite à
vos propositions je préfère le dire
clairement pour éviter les déceptions au
moment du débat
Véronique
louvagi vous dites que dans les 16
milliards d'euros il n'y a pas de baisse
structurel il y a l'entrée en vigueur de
baisse qui sont structurelles je pense
en particulier la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et puis je pense à vos
propositions vous avez faites dans
l'excellent rapport que vous avez
produit avec le député Robin Reda nous
nous sommes prêts à reprendre vos
propositions qui sont structurelles sur
l'efficacité de la dépense publique sa
publication des avis du Conseil d'État
je ne vous cache pas que je suis réservé
car je pense qu'il y a un risque
d'affaiblissement de l'État sur les
contentieux fiscaux en cours donc je
regardais la proposition de près j'ai
une petite réserve sur la croissance je
réponds à venir clovagym à tous les
députés qui m'ont interrogé sur le
chiffre de croissance moi juste rappeler
deux choses la première c'est que notre
prévision est en ligne avec les
prévisions de l'OCDE et du FMI
1,2,3% respectivement et vous faites
référence à la prévision de la Banque de
France je rappelle que l'estimation
basse de la prendre de France pour la
croissance 2023 en France était de moins
0,5
nous ont un
c'est un écart d'un point 5 par rapport
à la prévision de base la Banque de
France c'est un simple constat l'islam
amène à penser que notre prévision de
croissance pour 2024 est réaliste et
qu'elle est sincère
s'agissant du taux d'épargne vous avez
raison d'insister sur le fait que c'est
un élément absolument déterminant de la
croissance pour 2024 la singularité de
la croissance au deuxième trimestre 2023
c'est qu'elle a été tirée pour la
première fois par les exportations de
bien manufacturiers l'aéronautique et
pour la première fois depuis très
longtemps et Jean félicite EDF et tous
les agents d'EDF l'exportation
d'électricité produite par EDF avec le
retour de nos réacteurs nucléaires
le moteur qui aujourd'hui est à l'arrêt
c'est la consommation à cause de
l'inflation des inquiétudes et parce que
le taux dépanne a explosé il n'a jamais
été aussi élevé en France il est passé
de 15 à 19%
l'encours du livret a augmenté de 2,5
milliards d'euros pour le seul mois
d'août donc un des enjeux majeurs de la
croissance 2024 c'est de rassurer nos
compatriotes
sur notre politique économique et sur la
baisse des impôts et la sortie de la
spirale inflationniste pour que il se
remette à consommer et pourquoi
j'insiste avec Thomas Cazenave avec
autant de fermeté sur la stabilité de
notre politique économique sur les
impôts sur la confiance c'est que s'il y
a le moindre doute sur la stabilité de
notre politique économique vous ne
rallumerez pas le moteur de la
consommation hors nous voulons rallumer
le moteur de la consommation
Marina Ferrari je voudrais répondre à
votre question ainsi qu'à celle de
Christine Pirès Boon sur le logement je
le redis je partage d'évaluation qui a
été faite par le président de la
commission des finances par un certain
nombre d'entre vous sur la crise du
logement et l'urgence qu'il y a à
prendre un certain nombre de décisions
je le dis vraiment avec sincérité avec
mes convictions sur le prix des aides
nous avions décidé de restreindre son
accès je vais répondre très précisément
madame pires bonne est-ce que nous
sommes prêts à revoir le barème du prêt
à taux zéro oui
est-ce que nous sommes prêts à revoir le
zonage du prêt à zéro oui
donc nous sommes prêts à prendre des
décisions structurelles face à la crise
du logement pour apporter des réponses
immédiates aux primo-accédant est-ce
qu'il faut revoir les règles sur le
logement nul logements meublé je dis
attention car le risque de faire des
centaines de milliers de perdants et
très élevé je pense qu'il faut vraiment
regarder les choses de près avant de
s'engager mais je vous le dis nous
sommes ouverts sur cette question du
prêt à taux zéro car j'ai parfaitement
conscience que parmi les réponses
immédiates qui sont à notre disposition
il y en a pas des dizaines et celle là
en fait partie donc elle mérite d'être
regardée quant aux EHPAD je connais
votre combat sur le sujet je le salue et
je pense que nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler à l'occasion du débat
parlementaire
sur l'imposition minimale sur les
coopératives agricoles je rappelle qu'il
y a une règle qui a été fixée sur la
position minimale c'est qu'elle concerne
les entreprises qui réalisent un chiffre
d'affaires supérieur à 750 millions
d'euros appréciés sur une période plus
réelle pour éviter les effets de seuil
mais sans distinction du type d'activité
c'est le choix qui a été fait en
réaction aux remarques qui a été faite
sur la taxation sur les Gafa par
conséquent les coopératives fiscales
devraient être dans le champ de cette
imposition minimale je sais
naturellement que c'est compatible
agricoles bénéficient d'un régime fiscal
à l'impôt très favorable en France qui
s'explique par un souhait parfaitement
légitime et que je défends de traiter
d'accompagner le mieux possible le monde
agricole donc nous avons ouvert les
discussions avec les coopératives pour
trouver le meilleur chemin qui doit
permettre de concilier cet avantage
historique dont bénéficie des
coopératives et la mise en place de
cette imposition minimale à l'IS je vous
invite à participer à ces discussions
vous êtes la bienvenue
je pense que Thomas vous répondra sur la
rénovation des écoles
Nicolas sangsue sur les remarques que
vous avez fait sur l'énergie cher moi je
veux juste rappeler que nous avons mis
en place ce bouclier sur le gaz ce
bouquet sur l'électricité qui
représentait des économies de plusieurs
centaines d'euros par mois pour nos
compatriotes sur la facture
d'électricité enfin Charles de Courson
j'ai répondu cette président de
croissance je veux juste répondre sur un
sujet un tout petit peu plus général et
très rapidement ce que je partage là
aussi votre évaluation chose niveau de
croissance en Europe
parce que dans le fond la vraie
difficulté structurelle c'est pas le
niveau de croissance en France c'est le
niveau de croissance dans la zone euro
personne ne peut se satisfaire d'avoir
un niveau de croissance aussi faible
dans la zone euro au moment où les
États-Unis affichent un redémarrage
économique extrêmement dynamique où
l'Asie garde des taux de croissance qui
sont élevés
la zone euro vivote
mais c'est insupportable personne ne
peut se résigner à ça quel est le
problème de la zone euro c'est la
faiblesse des gains de productivité
depuis plusieurs années mais il faut
prendre à bras le corps ce sujet
continuez à investir innover
collectivement et traiter la question
des gains de productivité qui passe par
une réflexion approfondie sur nos
systèmes éducatifs nos systèmes de
formation et qualification tout cas
personne peut satisfaire d'avoir autant
d'états de la zone euro en récession et
les autres avaient une croissance faible
merci Thomas Cazenave merci monsieur le
Président en complément je voudrais
quand même redire à Jean-Philippe Tanguy
que nous sommes vus dans les cas de
dialogues de Bercy nous avons demandé à
chacun des groupes d'arriver et des
économies et hormis le changement de
politique monétaire qui ne relève pas du
PLF vous n'avez est-ce qu'il sait aucune
proposition concrète d'économie je
souhaitais vous le redire madame vous
pouvez toujours dire n'importe quoi mais
c'est la stricte réalité madame louvagi
pourrait Véronique globalgie pour vous
répondre sur la réforme du zonage rural
proposons vous verrez dans le dans le
projet de loi de finances on fusionne
trois types de zonage existants qui
arrivait à échéance fin d'année vous le
savez les edrr les ber et les orcho myR
afin de renforcer leur lisibilité et de
soutenir plus efficacement le
développement économique des territoires
ils sont remplacés par un nouveau zonage
qui s'appelle France ruralité
revitalisation qui sera décliné en deux
niveaux un niveau socle qui concerne
aura 14000 communes et un niveau
renforcé sur 4000 communes en gardant le
même champ d'activité éligible je le dis
compris les médecins parce que ça avait
été ça faisait partie des questions
notamment évoquées par les
parlementaires les exonérations fiscales
seront simplifiées et amplifiées et le
système sera dans l'ensemble simplifié
nous on peut s'engager à vous
transmettre dès que possible c'était je
crois le sens de votre question la liste
des communes intégrant donc le FRR
sur les questions
relatives Madame Christine Pirès bonje
peux vous confirmer deux choses oui nous
sommes favorables à la généralisation de
l'expérimentation sur les aviseurs
fiscaux qui n'est pas dans le texte
initial je compte combien dedans le
dialogue parlementaire
par voie d'amendements les groupes qui
voudront le défendre nous soutiendrons
ces amendements de même que les agents
de la Direction générale des finances
publiques et pas uniquement des
directions général de différences
publiques on regarde avec les douanes
pourront travailler sous alias aussi
alors à la fois c'est la capacité à
anonymiser leur travail dans des
situations un peu difficiles compliquées
ça c'est une disposition vous
retrouverez dans le dans le PLF sur les
EHPAD lors de la remise de votre rapport
à la première ministre la décider de
mettre en place un fond d'urgence à
destination des EHPAD de 100 millions
d'euros et d'autre part dans le PLFSS il
y a une expériment présentation pour
mettre sur pied d'autres modes de
financement des EHPAD et qui me semblent
aller dans le sens d'une réforme
structurelle de financement de
l'accompagnement du vieillissement
lise manier sur la question de la baisse
du psrue en fait en effet il baisse dans
le PLF 2024 vous allez avoir une baisse
du prélèvement qui correspond dans les
faits un retard notable dans la mise en
oeuvre du programme porté par la
Commission européenne notamment en
matière de politique de cohésion qui se
décaisse moins vite que ce qui était
prévu initialement mais cette baisse est
un peu en trompe l'oeil parce qu'on
attend 2025 un ressort du PSR
UE
madame
arigui président de la République en
effet de fait de la rénovation des
écoles un grand chantier et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il y a 500 millions
d'euros supplémentaires consacrés
à cette question là dans le PLF mais qui
n'épuise pas le financement public sur
la rénovation des écoles d'abord je le
redis c'est quand même la responsabilité
des collectivités territoriales qui
investissent et c'est comment on ne va
pas se substituer au collectivités
territoriales d'ailleurs elle le
prendrait très mal je pense la question
c'est comment on travaille avec elle oui
en renforce le fond vert pour qu'elles
investissent davantage et d'autre part
la Caisse des Dépôts porte un programme
qui s'appelle et du reino doté de 2
milliards d'euros pour tenir ses
engagements et enfin je le dis ici ici
nous avons adopté à l'unanimité une loi
sur le tiers financement en matière de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics qui trouvent si vous me
permettez l'expression un cas d'école
parfait en termes de mise en œuvre et
enfin s'agissant des RER métropolitains
le président de la République n'a pas
dit qu'il finançait l'ensemble des RER
métropolitains c'est un abondement dans
la négociation sur les CPER entre les
régions et l'État pour accélérer ce
chantier
merci on a commentateur supplémentaire
pour une minute je vous donne la liste
vous me dites s'il y en a d'autres et on
fait une notion de clôture Xavier
roseren Emilie bonivar Stella Dupont
Mohamed lakila Daniel la baronne
d'autres
c'est bon
un autre monsieur
ok allez on y va alors vraiment pas plus
minutieux
rosseren merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les ministres budget 2024 est
représentatif de notre responsabilité et
des choix fiscaux et budgétaires que
nous souhaitons faire je me félicite de
la hausse des budgets prioritaires 4
milliards d'euros dans l'armée la police
la justice la transition écologique à
hauteur de 40 milliards avec 7 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires et l'éducation
5,5 milliards messieurs les ministres
nous devons aller plus loin sur la
baisse du déficit public conformément à
notre trajectoire de dépenses d'ici 2027
la maîtrise d'un déficit public est
prioritaire je souhaiterais juste
attirer l'attention sur le logement un
projet de loi sur logement devrait être
annoncé dans les mois à venir toutefois
je suis convaincu que nous devons faire
des propositions fortes pour 2024 et
2025 dans nos PLF hier nos collègues ont
présenté les conclusions du rapport de
la mission d'information sur la
fiscalité du patrimoine et nous avons
rééquilibrer la fiscalité entre les
logements meublés et la location lue nue
longue durée vous nous avez annoncé
monsieur le ministre vouloir supprimer
la battement pour l'immeuble et classés
de tourisme mais sur les ministres
supprimer seulement cette abettement
serait un mauvais signal pour le
tourisme français et pour un gain très
réduit merci il est nécessaire d'aller
plus loin revoir en profondeur la
fiscalité de la location non meublée
professionnelle et nous avons réussi à
flat taxissons avec la fiscalité des
meublés merci Stella Dupont
monsieur le président
mais ce sera
l'importance des moyens consacrés à la
transition écologique 7 milliards
d'euros en crédit de paiement 10
milliards en autorisation d'engagement
c'est significatif mais nous vous
redisons messieurs les ministres notre
attachement à une trajectoire budgétaire
crédible face à la planification
écologique présentée donc cette semaine
j'ai deux questions une question qui
concerne les chambres de commerce et
d'industrie et la baisse de la taxe
affectée à hauteur de 25 millions prévus
dans dans ce PLF et la perspective d'une
baisse supplémentaire les années à venir
pour atteindre 100 millions d'euros
est-ce que vous pouvez me confirmer ce
chiffre ces chiffres ces données je
crois que on a réformé sur la précédente
législature le réseau j'ai participé
activement mais on a réduit la voilure
et je pense qu'on a besoin de ces outils
sur l'ensemble de nos territoires alors
qu'on porte une stratégie de pleine
emploi de développement de la formation
de l'apprentissage donc les CCI je suis
pour ma part très réservée à l'idée
qu'on réduise de nouveau leur moyen un
prélèvement sur fond de roulement est
envisagé
je lisse là qu'en est-il qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire et sur le
logement ça a été évoqué donc je vais
aller très vite on a tous été alerté et
on a maintenant des entreprises du
secteur qui sont en difficulté voir qui
sont des défaillances qui se
concrétisent j'ai un point technique
est-ce que il y a des mesures
d'éventuelles dispositions qui
viseraient à encourager l'investissement
locatif par des institutionnels de type
SCPI dans le secteur du locatif
intermédiaire parce qu'on a un sujet sur
toute la filière sur tout le parcours du
logement mais y compris sur
l'intermédiaire merci Émilie Bonivard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement moi ma question
portera également sur la question du
logement parce que je crois que nous
nous attendons tous les acteurs du BTP à
une crise majeure en 2024 et donc il
faut qu'on arrive à orienter ce sujet au
cœur de ce PLF on en est là aussi parce
que c'est le résultat d'une politique
depuis six ans très défavorable à la
construction et au logement je rappelle
que le gouvernement dès 2017 a voulu
réorienter les placements des Français
vers les capitaux mobiliers ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a un revenu immobilier
qui est de qui est prélevé à hauteur de
65% quand c'est 30% avec le pfu vous
ajoutez à cela la fin du Pinel sans
qu'on ait réussi à trouver un dispositif
de substitution Opinel et bien nous
sommes l'année prochaine face avec Chris
majeur du des capacités de des capacités
de logement et d'offres et nous ne
répondrons pas à cette difficulté sans
incitation fiscale à mon avis et
uniquement avec la réhabilitation des
logements donc voilà moi je souhaite
vraiment appeler votre attention
là-dessus et je rejoins ce qui a dit
roseren sur le sur l'hébergement
touristique merci on doit vraiment tenir
la minute parce que les ministres partir
au Sénat donc si vous voulez avoir des
réponses
Mohamed akila
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres une question de mon collègue
Olivier Falorni député de
Charente-Maritime qui déposera un
amendement au PLF 2024
compte tenu de l'importance croissante
de la mobilité douce et de l'objectif de
développement durable soutiendrez-vous
une modification de l'article L
3211 du code de l'environnement visa
alloué une partie des recettes du droit
départemental de passage à l'aménagement
et à l'entretien des pistes cyclables
aussi propre pour les îles maritimes
reliant le continent par un ouvrage
d'art comme le pont qui relie l'île de
Ré au continent merci merci Daniel la
baronne merci
Salut logement monsieur le ministre vous
soulignez l'intérêt de construire là où
nous avons besoin de logements or c'est
ses besoins se situe aujourd'hui dans
des territoires en réindustrialisation
et qui ne sont pas forcément dans les
zonages qui autorisent logement locatif
notamment intermédiaire je salue donc
votre volonté d'engager une révision de
saisonnage et je m'interroge sur les
modalités de mise en oeuvre de cette
révision par ailleurs vous proposez
d'élargir l'accès au PTZ créer un prêt à
bonifier mais ma question est la
suivante c'est deux initiatives
seront-elles emboîtées c'est-à-dire PTZ
et taux bonifié ou plutôt complémentaire
PTZ d'un côté taux bénéficier taux
bonifié de l'autre j'aurais souhaité des
éclaircissements sur ces initiatives
merci beaucoup Franck alizio
ce Président Monsieur les ministres
après un septena aux affaires vous
décidez vous décidez enfin à vous
attaquer certes timidement au problème
majeur que constitue la fraude dans
notre pays vol intolérable du fruit du
travail de compatriote la fraude est
d'autant plus inacceptable dans le pays
de tous les records d'impôts ou les
prélèvements obligatoires captent plus
de 45% de la richesse nationale et alors
même que vous avez laissé filer les
recettes fiscales supplémentaires dues à
l'inflation certains parlent de cagnotte
ça rappellera des souvenirs d'autres de
profiteurs de crise ou d'inflation
néanmoins nous restons sans surprise sur
notre fin avec quelques mesures
techniques qui ont le mérite d'exister
mais qui ne vont vraiment pas très loin
nous notons tout de même avec une
certaine satisfaction que vous avez
repris deux mesures que nous avions
proposées dans le cadre de notre
proposition de loi de lutte contre la
fraude déposée en avril dernier la
privation de droit aux réduction aux
réductions et crédit d'impôt pour les
fraudeurs dans une version certes
édulcorée et la lutte contre la pratique
les pratiques abusives en matière de
prix de transfert
aussi nous soutiendrons ces mesures nous
en proposons d'autres en attendant notre
question est simple est-ce là tout ce
que vous avez à proposer ou est-ce que
Gabriel Attal est-il parti avec les
brouillons déjà peu prometteurs de vos
mesures annoncées il y a quelques mois
deux minutes d'acides
oui une subvention de 2,5 milliards
d'euros est porté au crédit de
l'opérateur France compétences pour
assurer comme chaque année l'équilibre
financier d'une politique volontariste
de l'apprentissage que nous assumons et
qui vise à former un million d'apprentis
de moins de 30 ans comme s'il est engagé
le président de la République je
voudrais savoir quels sont les
indicateurs qui ont conduit à calibrer
la subvention à ce niveau là et de
penser ou pas qu'il faille quand même
regarder un peu de plus près et dans le
détail le versement de ses aides pour
que l'effort porte davantage sur les
grandes entreprises notamment et et les
qualifications de niveau supérieur je
vous remercie merci François Jolivet
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur les ministres pour votre
présentation moi j'aurais une question
sur le logement vous en doutez
l'économie de la construction
aujourd'hui en train de s'effondrer et
je voulais vous dire mes inquiétudes 50%
de la production du logement social est
liée aux opérations mixtes menées par
les promoteurs ils sont en train de
disparaître puisqu'en fait les accidents
d'appropriés et bien n'arrivent plus à
accéder du fait de la remontée des taux
les investisseurs comme l'a dit d'autres
l'ont dit d'autres collègues ont des
rentabilités qui aujourd'hui sont
effondrées avec le relèvement des taux
donc ça veut dire que en perspective
vous avez des promoteurs régionaux et
nationaux qui sont entrés dans des
dispositifs de plan sociaux
et vous avez également
des banques qui transforment le relais
de trésorerie en près de Bad bilan et ce
qui signifie qu'elle se disent qu'elle
pourrait peut-être les transformer en
action pour pouvoir contrôler les
promoteurs pour perdre moins d'argent le
logement c'est le secteur du logement
c'est un super talker il lui faut
beaucoup de temps pour s'arrêter il est
en train de s'arrêter il lui faudra
beaucoup de temps pour redémarrer
Charlotte Leduc
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres concerne la mise en oeuvre
du plan de lutte contre les fraudes
annoncés par votre prédécesseur Gabriel
Attal en juin dernier dans votre projet
de loi de finances on observe quelques
ajustements législatifs qui sont
bienvenus mais le cœur du problème sur
le sujet de l'évasion fiscale c'est
évidemment que sans moyens de contrôle
supplémentaire vos mesures n'iront pas
bien loin aucune augmentation réelle des
moyens du contrôle fiscal puisque les
1500 effectives supplémentaires sont des
redéploiements après la perte de 1500
1600 postes au cours des cinq dernières
années aucun changement de paradigme
pour en faire empêcher des vêtements de
l'impôt à grande échelle aucun moyen
supplémentaire non plus pour les
services d'enquête et de justice ma
question monsieur les ministres et la
suivante pourquoi ne faites-vous pas le
choix politique d'aller chercher les 80
à 120 milliards de manque à gagner par
an du à l'évasion fiscale un agent dans
le contrôle fiscal rapporte 1,5 millions
par an un agent à Tracfin c'est 30
millions de rentabilité en dehors des
redéploiements de moyens dans le
contrôle fiscal qu'en est-il de la
justice et des services d'enquête
ceux-ci sont pourtant nécessaires si on
veut réellement aller chercher les
milliards vous pourriez augmenter
considérablement les recettes de l'État
tout en rétablissement la justice
fiscale au lieu d'imposer au plus
modeste une austérité brutale merci et
enfin Karim
oui merci simplement pour dire que nous
apprécions à sa juste mesure
l'augmentation des moyens budgétaires et
humains de la mission action extérieure
de l'État mais je dois dire qu'elle est
à rapporter à ce que a subi notre
appareil diplomatique depuis près de 30
ans vous connaissez les conséquences de
ce démon du démantèlement de notre
appareil diplomatique vous connaissez
les conséquences sur le réseau
consulaire avec la crise des visas ou la
fragilisation sans précédent de nos
compatriotes les plus vulnérables nous
savons aussi désormais que sans
réarmement de notre diplomatie nous
fragilisons certaines de nos opérations
extérieures ainsi que le sel l'a montré
par exemple voir nous finissons par
briller par notre absence laissant place
à d'autres acteurs pas forcément
bienveillants ma question est donc
simple pouvons-nous confirmer que cette
augmentation s'inscrit dans une vision
pluriannuelle du réarmement de la
diplomatie et auquel cas pourquoi ne pas
reprendre les propositions des états
généraux de la diplomatie d'une loi de
programmation qui serait l'occasion de
repenser notre outil diplomatique à
l'aune des nouveaux enjeux face auxquels
nous ne sommes manifestement pas
outillés au vu de la succession de
déconvenues qu'on connaît notre pays et
dont les principales victimes
collatérales sont à ce stade nos
compatriotes installés à l'étranger
merci
merci messieurs les ministres
rapidement sur le président car nous
devons filer au Sénat
Xavier roseren choignement de la
fiscalité de la location je redis la
nécessité d'être prudent puisque le
majorité de bailleurs sont au régime
réel et n'opte pas peut-être pas
forfaitaire à 30% sur la location nue ou
50 % pour location meublée si on Aline
l'abattement de 30% sur celui de 50% par
souci de cohérence cela coûte 1 milliard
d'euros
si à l'inverse on baisse la battement de
50%, on fait plus de 500 000 perdants
donc il faut bien voir l'extrême
sensibilité de ces sujets donc je
propose que regardions cela ensemble
avant toute décision à l'inverse comme
certains l'ont proposé le PTZ on peut
faire ça rapidement y compris dans le
PLF si cela est souhaité par les
parlementaires cela Dupont choisi cette
dossier que nous suivons ensemble avec
plaisir depuis maintenant près de 7 ans
moi je constate que ce que nous avons
engagé ensemble c'est-à-dire le meilleur
équilibre entre les économies demandées
par l'État et la dynamique économique
des CCI fonctionne après je suis prêt à
rouvrir la discussion avec vous sur le
montant d'économie qui peut être demandé
raisonnablement au CCI je suis ouvert à
la discussion
Émilie Bonivard sur le logement je
partage évidemment votre analyse j'en
profite pour répondre aussi à Mohamed
Aquila Daniel la baronne sur ses sujets
là
on peut prendre des mesures immédiates
dans le PLF d'autres mesures je pense en
particulier auprès à taux bénéficier
vont demander plus de travail parce que
c'est des instruments complètement
nouveau et on les lance pas sans avoir
j'ai évidemment consulté déjà un stand
d'acteurs du secteur mais il faut que
les banques les bailleurs les
institutions financières soient prêtes à
participer je laisserai évidemment
Thomas répondre sur les questions de
fraude posée par Charles Leduc et Franck
alizio
Dominique Da Silva sur le logement
social moi je rappelle juste deux choses
que l'urgence c'était de sauver les
programmes qui étaient en cours on a la
fait par le rachat par la Caisse des
Dépôts habitat et Action Logement d'un
certain nombre de programmes c'est
l'accord que nous avons conclu en juin
où j'ai accepter un certain nombre de
choses pour que cet accord soit conclu
donc je pense qu'on a fait le nécessaire
je rappelle aussi que j'ai décidé de
plafonner le taux du livret A à 3,5%
pour trouver le bon équilibre entre la
rémunération des épargnants et le
financement du logement social ce qui
est un effort important ce que c'est
compliqué à expliquer nos compatriotes
qu'on plafonnent le taux du livret A à
3,5% en période d'inflation ça permet de
construire du logement social j'aimerais
qu'on n'oublie pas parce que ce genre de
choses quand on prend la décision
tout le monde nous en est reconnaissant
et le lendemain c'est oublié en revanche
nos compatriotes voient bien que le taux
du livret A est plafonné à 3,5% c'est
une décision que j'assume totalement que
je revendique je pense que les
équilibrée est juste mais j'aimerais que
les acteurs du logement social ne
l'oublient pas trop vite
enfin dernière question sur
la question de la politique étrangère et
du financement à l'action extérieure de
l'État je pense que ça peut faire
l'objet d'un débat utile au Parlement
merci Thomas kasdabe merci pour répondre
à la question de Stella Dupont sur la
question du logement intermédiaire on a
transformé l'exonération de taxe
foncières
en crédit en créance d'IS pour le
logement intermédiaire je crois que
c'était en 22 ou en 23 pour en
bénéficier il faut que la structure
juridique soit uniquement des personnes
morales et le PLF 24 étant la créance
d'IS au SCPI mais intégralement détenu
par des personnes morales j'espère que
ça répond à votre question
Mohamed lakila dès lors que l'évolution
vous proposait
n'entraîne pas une hausse du droit de
passage pour les usagers mais modifie
seulement l'utilisation de la ressource
par les collectivités concernées
ce qui s'inscrit dans mon objectif de
responsabilisation des collectivités
locales il me semble que c'est une bonne
idée à laquelle je pourrais être
favorable enfin Monsieur alizio plan
fraude d'abord traduction de 10
dispositifs législatif nouveau
c'est pareil loin de là ça crée divise
un plan froide qui contient par ailleurs
86 mesures tout n'est pas du niveau
législatif et je vous ferai un peu la
même réponse qu'à monsieur Tanguy sur la
question des froides a été mise sur la
table au dialogue de Bercy le groupe
socialiste par la voix de Christine
Pirès bonnet est arrivé avec des
propositions concrètes pour enrichir le
plan froide je n'ai pas entendu de
proposition de la part du rassemblement
national pour muscler un plan
probablement déjà suffisant à vos yeux
mais vous avez juste du mal à le
reconnaître et s'agissant de Madame
s'agissant de Madame Leduc sur le plan
fraude de la même manière je vous invite
à regarder le renforcement des
dispositifs de contrôle des prix
transfert un vrai sujet notamment pour
toutes les équipes en matière de
contrôle de contrôle fiscal nous créons
l'onaf nous créons l'onaf donc
transformant le service d'enquête
judiciaire en onaf avec 40 TP
supplémentaires et nous doublons le
nombre d'officiers judiciaires je
considère sur la question de la fraude
fisc ale sociale douanière voilà un
sujet sur lequel nous pourrions nous
retrouver il y a une véritable ambition
avec des évolutions concrètes très
attendues par les agents
bien merci messieurs les ministres
juste une petite chose je suis en train
de chercher avec mon cabinet la notation
sur l'exception française dans le
rapport du FMI sur la question
l'inflation je le trouve pas donc je
suis preneur de l'extrait ce que je ne
vois pas j'en vois pas de trace
je vous fournirai ça il y a aussi plus
simple à trouver c'est le rapport de
l'INSEE qui montrait clairement que
l'inflation est tirée par un
l'augmentation du prix des intrants de
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie et
en trois seulement les marges donc je
crois qu'il vaut mieux s'attaquer aux
sources de l'inflation plutôt que de
systématiquement mettre en avant des
marges que nous traitons par l'accord de
modération
mais j'attends l'extrait sur du FMI
qu'est-ce qu'il y a il faut vraiment
qu'ils s'en aille c'est juste une
précision ce que ce que nous avions
transmis à me au ministre Cazenave je
l'avais fait au nom de l'inter-groupe
nupestre dans tous je voulais juste le
préciser parce qu'on y a travaillé
ensemble merci merci
messieurs les ministres pour cette
audition on se retrouve à 21h15 pour
l'article 88 sur le LPF le signal en
commission c'est ravi mais